Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Moin.
Dazu wollte ich auch gleich was sagen.
Ich muss gerade noch mal ein Toastbrot fertig futtern.
BitConnect.
Was macht eigentlich?
Ich werde gerade mal gucken.
Da folgt das ja immer so am Rande.
Macht eigentlich der Bitcoin Kurs?
Sieht nichts.
Sekunde.
Okay.
Immer noch ein bisschen unten.
Dash Sword.
Dash Sword
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Aber auf der Arbeit
haben wir Bitcoins
Da haben wir auch.
Wir haben
Ether.
Polygon, ich weiß gar nicht wie die Tokens da heißen
äh nicht Tokens, wie die
Währung da heißt
ähm und Bitcoin
Polygon, Ether
Bitcoin
so, Toastbrot weg
achso, ich muss meine Pillen nehmen
tja, Moment, Moment
das muss sein
Sau.
Erledigt.
Ja, das wollte ich mir mit euch zusammen eh angucken.
wir können auch dann gucken ob ich
compromised bin
aber ich kann
eigentlich nicht compromised sein
weil wir haben zwar
in dem Zeitraum ein
Update gemacht, das hat man
im letzten Stream, war ja genau in dem Zeitraum
wo hier diese
Geschichte mit den manipulierten
Our Packages war, aber wir gucken uns das gleich an
aber
ich hab extra im Stream nochmal
im Wort nachgeguckt.
Wir haben
keine Our Packages
upgegradet, weil es keine Updates gab.
Okay, Luke,
Dankeschön
für den Pog Sub.
Mir läuft die Nase.
Wartet mal, ich mach mal mein Linux-PC an.
Ja, das ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass es dort versteckte Malware gab in our Packages.
Aber muss sagen, das ist jetzt keine Art spezifische Geschichte
Guckt euch NPM
Letztendlich war es übrigens unter der Haube war es wieder NPM
Das ist ja gerade der Witz
Es ist immer NPM, gefühlt
NPM in verschiedenen Varianten
Icon Packages waren ja auch mal betroffen
Die haben dann aber auch nur NPM Sachen nachinstalliert
Also npm ist da wirklich Hains-Champ.
So, zack, zack, da sind wir.
Ey, ich muss diesen Scheiß deinstallieren.
Ich tipp so oft Firefox und der startet mir dann dieses FLTK-GUI-Designer.
Wie kriege ich diesen Mist weg?
Warum ist das überhaupt installiert?
tk ok ist installiert warum was an installiert not tiger vnc warum habe ich tiger vnc überhaupt
installiert weg weg damit so und jetzt ist firefox wenigstens auf firefox und ich irgendwie
komische laggy oldschool GUI Zeug. Aha ja Moment, das ist das. Da kommen wir noch irgendwann im Lauf des Streams zu. So nochmal Updates machen. Aber keine
Our Packages updaten. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das schon erledigt ist. Also ich zeige euch das jetzt gerade mal. Für aller Art Linux User. Die ist
vielleicht nicht mitbekommen haben aber es gab einen supply chain angriff auf
das arch user repo hat ein scheiße dazu was veröffentlicht
angriffswelle auf 8 linux hunderte paket beschreiben mit mailware mdr ok also es
es so mittlerweile sind wir glaube ich bei über 1000 wenn ich das am anfang hieß es erst dass nur
400 ungefähr packages betroffen war aber ich glaube mittlerweile sind wir über 1000 packages
wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe also es wurden teilweise inaktive also verwaiste pakete im arch
user repo gehackermant und verseucht mit einem wenn ich es richtig im kopf habe
einem keylogger und und ich glaube noch irgendeinem anderen wegen der anderen
malware die ssh keys abzieht und wie das ganze funktioniert hat ist letztendlich
ist im arch user repo ja keine software direkt an gut geht auch noch okay im arch
user repo ist ja keine software direkt das sind ja quasi nur so wie heißt das
letztendlich sind so als bildscript speck speck file nee ich weiß nicht
mehr wie dieser kram speck file könnte das sein weiß es gar nicht mehr
letztendlich sind das ja nur so anweisungen wie das paket gebaut werden
package bild package bild genau genau das meine ich und das sind ja das ist
im prinzip einfach nur text file drin steht download url summe bla bla bla
was passieren soll und da gab es dann irgendwelche post
post install hooks oder sowas wo npm packages installiert wurden es wurde
npm package installiert das nannte sich irgendwas mit atomic
atomic lock oder so genau die haben das paket das npm wie gesagt es ist es ist
irgendwie ist es immer immer irgendwie npm ein paket installiert das atomic
lockt feil also es heißt total unschuldig ist aber nicht auf das
system brachte das enthielt ein präinstallation steht und wurde dateien
ausgeführt genau credentials die ist dealer ohne kilo angeblich auch
guck es gibt noch mehr also leute ihr solltet auf jeden fall aktuell nicht eure art user repo
Pakete updaten bis das alles wieder im Reinen ist. Mittlerweile ist wohl auch dieses Package
bei NPM delisted, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Der hatte keine Lust mehr auf YouTube.
Kann man denke ich so verkürzt sagen.
So, gucken wir mal bei NPM.
Da gab es hier dieses...
Genau, da gibt es ein Skript, um das zu testen.
Wobei ihr wisst ja, ich würde nicht unbedingt irgendwelche random Sachen aus dem Internet copy-pasten und nach Bash pipen
Aber, was ist denn PSAP?
Ach guck mal, das findet man auch nicht mal
Das findet man auch nicht mal
Wir gehen mal kurz hier oben, Package
Package
Atomic Log File, hier
Security Holding Package
Da ist nicht mehr wirklich viel drin.
Die haben das quasi depublished oder wie auch immer man das nennt.
Das war sonst das Package, was die ganze Malware-Geschichte enthielt.
Und das ist mittlerweile delisted.
Glücklicherweise wurde es nicht so oft runtergeladen.
ja, insgesamt noch 575
mal, aber trotzdem
da sieht man wieder, wie anfällig die ganzen
Repos und Sachen sind für solche Supply Chain
Angriffe, wir haben das ja im
JavaScript Ökosystem, also jetzt
war es immer NPM
die letzten Monate
und Jahre eigentlich schon, haben wir das ja
gefühlt alle, also mindestens
einmal im Monat gesehen
Da muss man echt aufpassen.
Was übrigens der Grund ist,
warum mittlerweile, wenn ich irgendwelche Sachen
entwickle, sei es jetzt in Go,
in C Sharp,
in JavaScript, gerade für irgendwelche Frontend-Sachen,
da kommst du ja um NPM nicht
drumherum. Ja, beziehungsweise,
natürlich ist es ja egal, ob du
mit NPM oder es mit BAN
oder mit Deno installierst. Wobei,
das nicht ganz stimmt.
ich bilde mir ein,
dass Deno, das kann aber auch sein,
dass ich da jetzt Mist erzähle,
Deno hatte irgendeinen
Security-Step eingebaut,
für solche Install-Hooks,
dass es da nicht so einfach funktioniert.
Da bin ich mir jetzt aber
nicht ganz sicher.
So.
Was ist das hier?
Och, ey,
wie mir diese Wallet-Geschichte auf den Keks geht.
koordinierte tag anders als user repo
ok da machen wir das doch mal wobei das ja nur anzeigt was wir für für package
also hier die diese dinge habe ich über das installiert
Habe ich denn überhaupt das hier installiert?
Ich sehe hier so ein Audio-Gedöns.
Warum ist das installiert?
Ups, das habe ich vertippt.
Schauen wir mal.
Ah, weil
VLC
FFM-Pack
Aber warum ist das aus dem
Auer-Install? Warum gibt es das nicht über offizielle
Package?
Ja, ne?
Warum habe ich das überhaupt installiert?
Warum zieht es nicht Sachen hier aus dem normalen Repo?
Yes.
Okay.
Und weg ist es.
Ja, also ich habe nur diese Dinger.
Die sind nicht, zumindest laut dieser Liste, nicht, nicht.
betroffen gewesen.
Okay, hier kann man
ausprobieren,
ob man betroffen ist.
Wir schauen uns jetzt mal kurz an,
was das Skript macht.
Okay, das hat eine Liste
mit Packages drin.
Das hat eine Liste mit Packages drinne, wo man dagegen checken kann, ob man betroffen ist.
Wäre es nicht sinniger gewesen, in das aktuelle Package Pile zu gucken,
ob da die NPM Sache drinne ist? Okay, das sieht relativ ungefährlich aus.
Dann pipen wir das mal nach Bash und gucken.
non of the non infected package reinstallt gut aber glück gehabt noch mal aber ich habe wie
gesagt das ist auch eines der gründe warum ich mittlerweile nur noch wenig art user packages
installiert haben also ich mich frage ist ob nix packages prinzipiell eine gute alternative zu art
User-Repo-Packages sind.
Weil bei
Nix hat
ja auch quasi
tausende Pakete
und man
muss nicht NixOS verwenden,
um
das installieren zu können,
um das benutzen zu können.
Da gibt es mehr oder weniger alles, was es
im Auer auch gibt. Das Ding ist nur,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das wirklich eine sinnvolle
Alternative ist, weil
ehrlich gesagt, könnte das
ja bei Nix Packages
ich bin da jetzt nicht so
tief drin, aber vom Ansatz her
könnte das ja bei Nix Packages
exakt genauso
passieren.
Ja, da sind ja unter
der Haube auch nur irgendwelche, ich nenn's mal
Build Scripts.
Also das kann ja bei Nix Packages
ganz genauso passieren wenn hier irgendwie einer kontrolle über dieses repo bekommt und bäumen hat
man es also dass das macht also vielleicht sehe vielleicht über sehe ich da jetzt irgendwas aber
das macht jetzt eigentlich wenig unterschied die warum es wahrscheinlich er beim art user repo ist
als bei nix us vielleicht beim art user repo und ticken einfacher das weiß ich nicht aber es geht
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen um die verbreitung und ich denke mal dass nix package und nicht so
verbreitet sind. Archie-Lux ist ja mittlerweile
ziemlich verbreitet und
installieren auch viele Leute natürlich was aus dem Archie-User-Repo.
Also keine Ahnung.
Also ich denke, das ist jetzt
auch nicht wirklich eine Alternative,
weil es da im Prinzip ganz genau
so passieren kann.
Es kann im Prinzip überall
passieren. Das kann
sogar, wenn man es jetzt mal übertrieben sieht,
das kann sogar bei
offiziellen Paketen aus offiziellen
Distro-Repos passieren.
Da ist natürlich die Hürde ein bisschen höher, aber wenn da beispielsweise der Package-Maintainer sich irgendein Rootkit einfängt auf seinem Rechner und die Kontrolle über seinen Rechner haben und dort in irgendwelchen offiziellen, sagen wir mal, Debian-Packages was verstecken und das gut verstecken, könnte das theoretisch auch darin landen.
Die Höhen sind natürlich auch deutlich höher.
Da gucken wir noch mehr Leute drauf.
Dann dauert es eine Weile, bis das released ist.
Also das ist da recht unwahrscheinlich aus den offiziellen Paketquellen von, sagen wir mal, Debian.
Potenziell kann das natürlich überall passieren.
Und wir haben es auch gesehen, erinnert sich vielleicht noch einer an Notepad++.
Hier.
Notepad++.
da war das auch so und das waren offizielle repos ja und
xz utils hat man auch genau ja ja also das kann schon passieren und
xz utils war wirklich knapp dass da was passiert ist
ob er notepad plus plus letztendlich auch also es kann euch überall passieren und das bist das
das große problem was ich da sehe ja notepad plus plus auf server windows windows aber gut
kann ich sogar verstehen weil das offizielle notepad sagt halt es ist halt ein bisschen doof
weil man könnte jetzt ja sagen ey wisst ihr was wir warten einfach mit updates ins wir warten
einfach mit update installation ja also sprich wir installieren einfach so blöd wie das man
jaro macht so nach dem motto wir machen einfach wir warten einfach zwei wochen mit updates einfach
zwei wochen gewartet wenn in der zeit nichts aufgefallen ist ist die chance sehr hoch dass
nichts drin ist ja kann man machen das problem ist aber dass du auf der anderen seite die dann
wieder Probleme einfängst,
durch andere Sicherheitslücken,
die genauso kritisch sein können,
jetzt halt nicht irgendwelche Sachen, die
Supply Chain Angriff mäßig
untergeschoben wurden, sondern Sicherheitslücken,
die wirklich in der Software halt drin sind.
So, und wenn man da jetzt immer zwei Wochen
mit installieren, hast du da
das Problem, dass du da wieder anfällig bist.
Und da gab es ja auch in letzter Zeit genug.
Letztendlich,
keine Ahnung,
was da
das beste Vorgehen ist,
also ich stelle mir es
so aktuell vor,
das Beste, was man machen kann,
vielleicht ist es auch Blödsinn, muss ich auch rausstellen,
ist tatsächlich
die
besonders
vertrauenswürdigen
Pakete, also
im Prinzip unter Linux das, was
aus den offiziellen Paketquellen kommt,
die möglichst schnell zu installieren
und auch das meiste
daraus zu installieren, wo es geht,
Das ist ja geil.
Acht Jahre Moderator.
Pogmax.
Exzellente Subscription.
Leute, Leute, wir brauchen jetzt, bevor ich weiter labere,
wir brauchen jetzt einmal für den Max,
einmal im Chat,
Modcheck,
einmal alle, die da sind, Modcheck.
Weil acht Jahre und immer noch am Start
und immer noch am Moderaten und immer noch am Wubblos.tv weiterbasteln.
Excellent.
Oh, seven.
Ja, schön, dass du am Start bist.
Community, ja, genau.
Wo war ich jetzt stehen geblieben gerade?
Genau, also das, was ich mir am besten vorstelle, ist,
man installiert Packages aus vertrauenswürdigen Quellen, also in dem Fall sind es Linux,
sind es die offiziellen Pakete aus den offiziellen Distro-Repos.
Die installiert man schnell, dass man irgendwelche Sudo-Lücken, SSH-Lücken
und was es nicht alles in letzter Zeit gab, möglichst schnell abgefackelt hat.
Und Arch-User-Repo und solche Sachen oder irgendwelche Custom-Dinger, die man installiert hat,
da
wartet man
einfach ein bisschen
letztendlich ist es einfacher gesagt
als getan, denn
selbst wenn ich jetzt sage
ah ok, ich warte jetzt immer 2 Wochen
zwischen den Update-Läufen
ja, wenn ich hier ein Update mache
alle 2 Wochen, dann kann es ja durchaus
sein, dass gestern
irgendein Paket Malware bekommen hat
also das ist gar nicht so einfach, sich davor zu schützen
so wirklich
100% sicher
kann man eigentlich mittlerweile
nicht mehr sein
deswegen ist es sinnvoll
meiner Meinung nach
möglichst
wo es geht
auf Sand geboxte
Environments zu setzen
also sprich
wenn man Sachen entwickelt
das vielleicht in Dev-Containern zu machen
oder eine extra VM zu haben, wie ich hier.
Wobei, einen extra Rechner quasi zu haben, wie ich hier.
Wo keine privaten Sachen drauf sind.
Wenn man dann irgendwie...
Aber das lässt sich alles nur bis...
Man ist sich sicher.
Also das schützt dann auch nur in grenztem Maße vor solchen Angriffen.
Also aktuell ist es wirklich schwierig.
Ich glaube...
glaube, wisst ihr, was theoretisch
das sicherste wäre,
was aber nicht praktikabel ist?
Das sicherste wäre
sowas wie Gentoo,
alles selbst kompilieren
und
Changes für
jedes Paket von Hand
lesen.
Das wird
aber keiner machen und das ist nicht
handelbar, ja?
Also das könnte man machen,
dann wäre man, wenn man da auf Zack ist,
wäre man so sicher wie irgendwie geht aber das ist halt nicht praktikabel
kein internet anschließend keine updates man das kann man auch machen
kann die ki den code durch forsten bestimmt stimmt kannst du das mal du
wirst dann trotzdem Sachen haben, die dann durchgehen.
Vielleicht ist es auch
an der Zeit, sowas zu machen. Vielleicht machen
das ja auch die Repo-Betreiber schon.
So nach dem Motto, ey,
bei jedem Package, was hochgeladen wird,
gibt's jetzt einen...
Wie heißt
es? Es heißt ja nicht mal Mythos,
es heißt ja jetzt...
Ich hab vergessen, wie das...
Wie heißt das neue Anthropic-Ding?
Was jetzt
was jetzt angeblich wieder gesperrt ist.
Fable, Fable, ja.
Das ist ja mittlerweile gesperrt.
Oh, Chat geht sellout time. Ich seh's gerade in der Vorschau.
Chat, Chat.
Diesen Monat ist
Sponsoring angesagt von
Ugreen, Seagate und Alternate.
Ich finde es
nett, dass der Chat
mich da drauf hinweist.
Wenn ihr auf der Suche nach günstigem Storage seid,
könnt ihr jetzt
in Chat
Ausrufezeichen Seagate, Ausrufezeichen Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Alternate eingeben.
Oder ihr geht auf mein Channel und klickt das hier an.
Und da könnt ihr euch hier mal die Angebote durchgucken.
Es gibt ziemlich günstige Festplatten.
Und es gibt ziemlich günstige Ukraine Assets.
Die Ukraine Assets sind von der, quasi vom, wie nennt man das?
eher aus dem Einstiegssegment,
haben aber den Vorteil,
sie sind günstig und
sie verbrauchen sehr wenig Strom.
Und für den Heimbereich
reicht das.
Wenn man jetzt nicht so à la Techno-Tim das machen will,
mit 5 Kubernetes-Cluster
daheim, dann ist das
preis-leistungsmäßig nicht schlecht.
Könnt ihr euch ja mal angucken.
Genau.
So, jetzt muss ich mir erstmal den Chat angucken, weil ich jetzt irgendwie 20 Minuten gelabert habe über Supply Chain Angriffe und sonst was.
Ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Ja, das Dienungs-Desktop, damit wird das als Angriffsziel immer attraktiver.
letztendlich, ja
das ist auch ein Faktor
früher war das ja nicht so, dass Linux nicht
angreifbar war, mit solchen Sachen
Linux war einfach nicht verbreitet
genug, dass es sich gelohnt hat
aber nachdem immer mehr
gerade die letzten
zwei, drei Jahre
das letzte Jahr insbesondere
es immer mehr zugenommen hat
dadurch, dass Leute
wie PewDiePie Linux Videos machen
Linux Tech Tips ist ja da auch mittlerweile am Start,
wobei ich mir die nicht angucken kann.
Das ist mir zu Pains Champ, mir die anzugucken.
Steam Deck und solche Geschichten.
Da hat sich ja enorm viel getan.
Der Anteil von Linux bei Privatusern ist ja auch immer weiter gestiegen.
Und wir haben jetzt halt ein Level erreicht.
Man kann das ja auch positiv sehen.
Wir haben jetzt ein Level erreicht, wo Linux so verbreitet ist,
und wohl auch insbesondere Arch Linux,
so verbreitet ist, dass es sich lohnt, gezielt Supply Chain Angriffe zu fahren für End-User unter Linux.
Früher war das genauso.
Also du hattest früher genau die gleichen Angriffsvektoren.
Aber bei 0,1% der Verbreitung hat es dir halt keiner die Mühe gemacht.
Im Prinzip war das so eine Frage der Zeit, bis das passiert.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass die Repo-Betreiber auch versuchen werden, da irgendwie gegenzusteuern.
Beim Arch User Repo, dass man sich erstmal das Handling von verwaisten Paketen anguckt, wie das ist, wie das andere Leute übernehmen können.
Dass man tatsächlich vielleicht irgendwie sowas macht wie Fable oder so bei Pushes oder bei veröffentlichten Paketen reinhaut und sich das angucken lässt.
Das wird ein Wettrennen, wie das schon lange Zeit mit Virus- und Antivirensoftware ist, wird es da auch sein.
Und ich denke, dass sich da schon in nächster Zeit ein paar Security Steps etablieren werden.
Ganz aus dem Weg schaffen wird man es nicht können.
So Sachen wie beispielsweise bei Notepad++ passiert sind.
oder bei hier
XZ-Utils
bei solchen Geschichten
so richtig 100%ig was dagegen machen
wirst du nie können
ist aber auch kein Unterschied zu früher
wo man gesagt hat, ey
wenn du dir
einen neuen Virus eingefangen hast, wo dein Virenscanner
auch keine Signaturen hat, der in den Verhaltenskennungen
nicht aufgefallen ist
du warst nie 100%ig sicher
also, dementsprechend
das Wichtigste
was es immer, immer gilt, seit Jahren, seit Anfang an, ja, ist brain.exe, ist nicht verkehrt.
Aber selbst das hilft nämlich gegen alles.
ich hab letztens
eine ganz merkwürdige
E-Mail bekommen
da hab ich sofort dran gedacht
ich werde hier gefischt
war es aber gar nicht
vielleicht habt ihr die auch bekommen
ich hab eine Mail bekommen von
irgendwas aus den USA
irgendeine Sammelklage
gegen Amazon
und ich wurde darüber informiert
dass ich ja beim Amazon
marketplace was gekauft habe und ich das jetzt deswegen jetzt teil der sammelklage sein kann
oder sowas vielleicht habt ihr das auch bekommen ja und da habe ich erst gedacht was ist das die
wollen die wollen mich das war ich war mir so sicher dass das irgendein phishing ding ist
was mich halt gewundert hat ist dass es auf meine spezial e mail adresse also ich habe
E-Mail-Adresse plus Amazon
irgendwas, ne,
dass ich gesehen hab, dass das
direkt für die E-Mail-Adresse ist,
die ich für Amazon angelegt hab,
und
dann hab ich mal gegoogelt,
und da kam raus,
nein, das ist wirklich eine richtig
offizielle Sammelklage
gegen Amazon, und
in den USA ist es wohl so,
wenn du da
von betroffen bist,
dann musst du informiert werden und sowas.
Ganz weirdes Zeug, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Weiß nicht, Chad, hat vielleicht von euch auch so einer was gekriegt?
Irgendwelche
Class-Suit oder wie
sich das bei den Amis nennt.
Ganz merkwürdige Mail. Ich war so
instant überzeugt, muss ein Phishing-Versuch sein, war es dann aber gar nicht.
Weird Champ.
Du darfst das auch scammen.
Ja.
Sehr merkwürdig.
Nun gut.
Hätten wir das Thema auch abgehakt.
Muss ich erstmal Chat lesen.
Weil ich wieder die Hälfte vergessen hab.
hier.
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Das hatten wir schon.
Was war hier das Ding?
Wie kann ich rausfinden,
ob mein PC compromises?
Habe keine Hour Package.
Dann bist du nicht compromised.
In dem Fall.
dann bist du nicht kompromiss also die offiziellen cash und art user repropakete war nicht betroffen
ansonsten ist diese software in der regel relativ gut drin sich zu verstecken also
das ist gar nicht mal einfach rauszubekommen ob man kompromiss ist oder nicht wenn man die vermutung
hat ist wahrscheinlich das beste das system neu zu installieren ja du kannst auch das machen was
geschrieben wurde im chat wenn du kannst natürlich auch gucken dass du irgendwie den traffic auswertet
wobei das einfacher gesagt ist als getan es gibt verdammt viel traffic dort was verdächtiges zu
finden ist teilweise nahezu unmöglich wenn es https verbindungen sind kannst
du ihn oder nach gegen welche ziele das geht und das also das ist das ist das
ist echt nicht so einfach ja es raus zu bekommen kann es natürlich die die
doch in der mittel tls proxys erdbauern wurde kommt alles ist nicht einfach
Also ich würde mich nicht darauf verlassen, dass wenn ich mein System analysiere, wirklich
mir danach hundertprozentig sicher wäre, dass ich nichts übersehen habe.
Das Zeug ist gut da drin sich zu verstecken.
Also wenn du da irgendwelche Bedenken hast, ist wahrscheinlich besser neu zu installieren.
aber wenn du keine packages hat ist es in dem fall als nicht als user wie weiß man ob man
auch packages installiert hast wenn du kein art user bist hast du keine art user repos
packages installiert das ist das heißt art user repository also das ist das gibt es nur
für art und für cash also für art abkömmlinge auch cash us und sowas es gibt aber sich andere
Varianten, wie du dir Sachen einfangen kannst.
NPM-Packages, Notepad++
und was es nicht noch alles gibt.
Da habe ich mich jetzt ja eine Weile drüber ausgelassen.
Also 100% sicher.
Du kannst dir sicher sein, dass du keine Arch-User-Repro-Packages
installierst, wenn du keinen Arch hast.
Das ist schon mal klar.
Dass du dir nie irgendwas einfängst,
wird man nicht sicherstellen können.
Das einzige, was hilft,
ist Brain.exe.
Aber selbst das hilft einem
nicht immer.
Neue Installation, das ist das Beste.
Am besten ist, ihr habt auch regelmäßig ein paar Backups gemacht.
Zumindest eure wichtigen Daten.
Wisst ihr, ich bin ja der Meinung, für viele ist Backups anlegen eine relativ große Hürde.
Weil die denken sich, ey, wir müssen das ganze System irgendwie backuppen, schnell recoveren können.
Musste gar nicht.
Du musst nicht dein gesamtes System backuppen und möglichst schnell recoveren.
Musste in der Regel daheim auch nicht.
Du kannst ja auch einen USB-Stick machen an einem anderen Rechner und es neu installieren.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Wichtig ist, ihr müsst euch überlegen, welche Daten wirklich wichtig sind.
Und das ist meistens weniger, als man denkt.
Ja, es ist easy zu sagen, ich mache das ja letztendlich auch so, ja.
Es ist easy zu sagen, ich backupe einfach das gesamte System.
Ja, das hat dann natürlich ein paar Hürden.
Du brauchst ein großes NAS oder irgendwas.
Du brauchst vielleicht noch ein Backup vom Backup, beziehungsweise ein Backup vom NAS,
weil du sagst, hey, auf dem NAS liegt halt immer das Aktuelle,
aber ich will auch eine History haben und sowas.
Wenn du dir mal genau überlegst, was für Daten wirklich kritisch sind, ja,
dann ist das meistens gar nicht so viel.
Dann ist das meistens ein paar Gigabyte.
Das sind vielleicht ein paar sehr persönliche Familienfotos und sowas, ja, also so unwiederbringbare Dinger.
Das sind so Sachen wie Passwortsafe, SSH-Keys und solche Geschichten.
Das ist meist, also die Sachen, wo man sich wirklich überlegen muss, die wirklich wichtig sind, die du auf gar keinen Fall verlieren willst,
das ist meistens nicht so viel.
Das sind dann, das sind ein paar 100 MB bis ein paar Gigabyte.
Das ist meistens nicht so viel.
und das kann man dann
dadurch, dass es nicht so viel ist
einfach regelmäßig wegsichern
und am besten dann auch irgendwie nachts mal
auf eine zweite Platte und gut ist
ja und dann ist halt die Recovery Time, die man hat
ein bisschen länger, dass man
sagt, oh Mist, ich glaube
ich hab mir was eingefangen
ich mach mal alles platt
und
mach mir einen USB-Stick am zweiten Rechner
installiere Windows oder Linux neu
und ziehe ein Backup von vor ein paar Tagen wieder drauf.
Also von den wichtigen Dateien.
Rest richtig von Hand ein.
Ist man halt dann zwei, drei Tage,
bis alles wieder genauso ist, wie man es haben will, beschäftigt,
dafür muss man im Vorfeld nicht diese große Hürde mit
Oh, wie mache ich so einen voll recoverable Backup-Plan?
Diese Hürde überwinden,
was bei vielen Leuten eher dazu führt, dass sie sagen,
machen wir halt gar nicht und das halt aufschieben.
Der erste Schritt ist wirklich die essentiell wichtigen Daten,
die man braucht. Wie gesagt, sowas wie Passwortsave,
SSH-Keys,
persönliche Fotos, Andenken,
Sachen, die halt wirklich persönlich wichtig sind,
die regelmäßig zu sichern.
Und dann ist man schon mal
viel entspannter unterwegs.
Oh, ich hab heute nicht gut gepennt, Leute.
Hat mir wieder zu viel Gedanken gemacht, ey.
Wann kommt der Zeitpunkt, wo wir alle zu Windows wechseln, weil es sicherer ist, weil es keiner nutzt?
Letztendlich, vieles ist ja so eine Bounce-Bewegung, wer weiß.
Vielleicht sind in 20 Jahren auf dem Desktop, also ich meine ohne Scheiß, wenn Microsoft so weitermacht, ne?
kann das durchaus sein,
dass wir in 20 Jahren alle auf
Linux sind. Oder auf
BSD oder so.
Ich mein, Microsoft reitet ja
was Windows angeht von einer Kacke in die
nächste Scheiße, so.
Da muss man sich wundern.
Ja, vielleicht ist es so. Vielleicht sind wir in 20
Jahren alle unter Linux
und irgendwas wird da total verkackt,
dass die Leute wieder anfangen auf Windows. Ey, wer
weiß es nicht, ja.
diese sache ja das hat alles alle art alle art distros betroffen aber nur als user repo
packages video gefunden wahrscheinlich zu lang werde ich jetzt gerät rollt das ist zu lang für
den stream bluetooth smart communication von gadgets analysieren okay das ist das ist glaube
zu high IQ für mich und auch zu lang mit streamen und ich glaube das interessiert
wahrscheinlich auch nicht so viele
aber in sich klingt es nicht schlecht vielleicht guck ich mir das nachher auf dem Handy an
von was von was war das von?
um CCC okay
ah ne GPN24
Da habe ich letztens ein Video geguckt schon von
GPN24, das ist übrigens nicht
ja, das ist der 24.
Ausgabe, nicht 2024.
Da habe ich ein Video über SSH Tunneling
geguckt und das fand ich nicht gut.
Das fing
vielversprechend an und
im Prinzip war 50% des Videos
irgendwelche sinnlos Fragen und Wichtigtuer
Verbesserungen aus dem Publikum und
es kam kaum was bei rum. Also das fand ich
nicht gut.
Hast du heute Muskelkater?
Ich merke es ein bisschen in den Beinen.
Nö, aber es geht.
Geht ganz gut.
Also ich bin gestern ein bisschen über 11 Kilometer gerannt.
Und das ging erstaunlich gut.
Mir tut auch nichts.
Im Schienbein weh und sowas.
Ich hatte ja vor ein paar Wochen das Problem,
da hatte ich am Schienbein einen dicken Knubbel.
Das hat sich irgendwie entzündet.
Der ist jetzt so gut wie weg.
Und mir hat das auch weh getan.
und da habe ich mal vier Wochen
gar nichts gemacht
bis das alles wieder weg war
und dann habe ich langsam angefangen
also ich bin dann erstmal nur eine kleine Runde gelaufen
zwei Tage Pause gemacht, kleine Runde gelaufen
zwei Tage Pause gemacht, bisschen näher gelaufen
zwei Tage Pause gemacht, dann nur noch einen Tag Pause gemacht
also ich habe das quasi dann über ein, zwei Wochen
langsam wieder hochgefahren
und jetzt kann ich
mehr oder weniger jeden Tag
kleine bis große Runde
rennen mit ab und zu mal
so einen Tag die Woche Pause,
ohne dass mein Schienbein
gleich wieder anfängt, Probleme zu machen.
Also, das kann ich euch echt
auch nur empfehlen, wenn ihr mal eine Weile nichts
gemacht habt und wieder anfängt,
gerade mit Laufen, das geht halt sehr auf Schienbein,
dann
mit kleinen Runden anfangen, Pause machen
und so langsam
über zwei, drei Wochen das steigern,
weil ansonsten hast du ratzfatz irgendwas am Schienbein
und musst wieder aufhören und musst wieder Pause machen.
Lebt die Uhr noch?
Gibt es... Keine Ahnung, was die Uhr macht.
Die liegt irgendwo im Main.
Achso.
Für alle, die das Video
nicht gesehen haben.
Ich kann euch das ja gerade nochmal
vorspielen.
Ich glaube, ich habe das sogar schon mal im Stream
angedeutet vor einer Weile.
Dass ich meine Garmin-Uhr in den Main geschmissen habe.
Angedeutet.
Wobei ich da, glaube ich, irgendwas anderes erzählt habe
im Stream, weil es mir peinlich war zu sagen,
ich habe meine Garmin-Uhr in den Main geschmissen.
Da habe ich im Stream
irgendwas angedeutet, so nach dem Motto
ich war kurz davor, meine Uhr wegzuschmeißen
oder irgendwie sowas.
Tja, okay.
Wir gucken uns das gerade das Video von mir nochmal an.
Ich habe gestern
extra aufgenommen.
Ein bisschen leise, hä?
Moment, Moment, Chat.
Das müssen wir mal, glaube ich, ein bisschen...
Wartet mal.
Kriegen wir das hier ein bisschen lauter irgendwie?
Man hat ja hier keine...
Ah, hier, okay.
Volle Pulle. Sekunde, Sekunde.
Ah, jetzt. Jetzt ist gut, oder?
Jetzt versteht man es, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Der Sound wird übrigens besser nach den ersten 10 Sekunden.
ich weiß versteht man
sicherlich alles aufs kreuz konzert
langen logan wie man so schön
kilometer 634 zumindest ich dachte mir ja nicht so gerne ist mir recht langweilig ist jetzt bin
ich noch was wusste jetzt und zwar diese gramm nur hier wenn ihr das wird jetzt kein sehr laut
die vegane Uhr. Hier ist nicht mal meine
originale Garmin Uhr,
weil
die alte Garmin Uhr
habe ich in Main geschmissen.
Main ist ein Plus bei Frankfurt.
Und warum?
Ich habe
das letzte halbe Jahr, also
letztes Jahr,
2025, habe ich das letzte halbe Jahr
kaum was gemacht.
Weder Rennen noch Fahrradfahren, sonst was.
Bei der zweiten Runde,
als ich wieder angefangen habe hat meine uhr gesagt hey komm auf geht's ich glaube 35 minuten
locker locker rennen und ich hab's nicht locker angegangen und mir die brücke hoch geflitzt bei
uns und ich hatte den übelsten krampf rechts neben dem schienbein ich wusste gar nicht dass
man da muskeln hat zumindest war ich so sauer und es hat so weh getan dass ich mir gedacht habe
die gleiche noch mal ganz schön angekommen 17
also wir sehen uns demnächst bestimmt auch mal wieder auf youtube ist denn macht's gut
Ich finde das gut,
dass ich irgendwie ganz instinktiv
real life in Twitch-Emotes rede.
Keck weh, Alter.
Ja.
Glücklicherweise
Was?
Chat.
Ey, was wollte ich sagen?
Glücklicherweise hat meine Mutter die gleiche Uhr.
und die benutze ich jetzt.
Also, beziehungsweise,
ich hab der
vor einer Weile die gleiche Uhr
gekauft.
Und dann
benutze ich die jetzt, weil die war die kaum benutzt.
Die ist da irgendwie, kommt damit nicht klar.
Also, die
die hat kein Gefühl für wie man technische Sachen
bedient. Das ist so ganz weird.
Ja, also
kennt ihr das, wenn ihr
Leute habt, die
Technik nur nach
How-to bedienen können und nicht
instinktiv.
Also sprich,
ich hab dir gesagt, okay,
wenn du jetzt hier irgendwie dein
Spaziergang machst, dann musst du
hier auf Start drücken, wählst aus
das hier Walken,
drückst auf Start, nochmal auf Start und dann
fängt es an. So, das checkt die nicht.
Die checkt diesen Ablauf
nicht.
Was sie kann ist, wenn die auf dem Startbildschirm ist und ich ihr sage, du drückst jetzt Start einmal nach unten und zweimal Start, das kann die.
Die merkt sich dann aber nicht im Kopf, ich gehe in das Aktivitätenmenü mit Start, ich wähle Laufen aus und drücke dann nochmal Start, um es zu bestätigen, nochmal Start.
Das denkt die sich nicht. Die versteht das nicht. Die versteht den Ablauf nicht. Die versteht einfach nur, ich muss quasi dreimal Start drücken oder so. Die versteht den Zusammenhang nicht.
und wenn die mal nicht im Startmenü ist
von der Uhr, kriegt die es nicht hin
es ist unmöglich
also ich verstehe das nicht
das ist
also wenn du der sagst
hey, so und so geht das, kann die das
weil die sich nicht
die, wisst ihr was ich meine
also es gibt Leute, die verstehen die Bedienung
von Geräten relativ instinktiv
die verstehen dann
wann das Gerät von einem will, dass man die Zurück-Taste drückt
wann das Gerät vornan will, dass man die Start-Taste drückt,
wann das Gerät will, dass man die Taste drückt.
Die verstehen das.
Und es gibt Leute, die verstehen das einfach nicht.
Die können nur stumpf nach Tutorial vorgehen.
Und Tutorial ist dann quasi sowas wie, drücke einmal nach unten, zweimal Start, Start.
So, und wenn der Ausgangsbildschirm ein bisschen anderer ist, dann geht's nicht.
So, und deswegen hat die die Uhr kaum verwendet.
Wenn man das letzte Mal wieder ausprobiert, das klappt einfach nicht.
Tja, jetzt verwende ich die Uhr.
Wo du tauchen musst.
Weiß nicht, wo die jetzt hingespült ist mittlerweile.
Ich glaube nicht, dass diese Uhr einfach direkt sinkt.
Ah.
Das sind Technik-Boomer.
Es geht.
Die ist da eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm.
Auf ihrem iPad checkt die die Sachen auch zum größten Teil.
Was ihr da nicht checkt, sind so Sachen wie...
Also, guckt mal.
Ihr könnt, mal angenommen, ihr habt eine App offen unter iOS.
So, und die App, die ist irgendwie hängen geblieben oder hat irgendwie diesen komischen State und funktioniert nicht.
Was macht man dann?
Man geht in den Task Manager und macht die App zu und macht die App nochmal auf.
So, und dann geht es in der Regel wieder.
Das Ding ist nur, meine Mutter versteht den Unterschied nicht zwischen App schließen und App beenden.
Also du kannst ja einfach nur hoch
wischen.
Schon wieder Sellout.
Das soll eigentlich nur alle halbe Stunde kommen.
Ist ja schon wieder eine halbe Stunde rum.
Das kann doch gar nicht sein.
Ist doch erst 10 Minuten her oder so,
wo ich Sellout gemacht habe.
Massive Sellout.
Also wenn ihr auf der Suche seid,
nach künstlichem Storage, Leute.
Oh, fuck.
Ich habe wieder den Streamtitel vergessen.
Oh, Mann.
Ich habe den Streamtitel wieder vergessen.
Monk HW.
Ich muss den Streamtitel mal editieren.
Kann man das irgendwie editieren?
Den Titel oder so? Geht das?
Ah ja, geil.
Okay, so.
Im Wort haben wir es schon mal gespeichert.
Weil ich muss ja den
Streamtitel
anpassen.
Jetzt haben wir es.
Ne, ich muss nicht Riesdaten.
Ich habe den
wort schon editiert okay passt btf wieder vergessen ausrufezeichen sie
gehen ausrufezeichen ukraine im chat wenn ihr günstigen storage haben wollt
und ukrain nass ist
Das stimmt.
Ich habe so viele Tabs, dass es nicht mal ein Trennsymbol gibt.
Omega-Lul.
Das ist richtig.
Ja, was ich sagen wollte, die versteht halt den Unterschied nicht zwischen Anwendung schließen und Anwendung beenden so.
Oder Anwendung minimieren, Anwendung beenden.
Am iPad kannst du ja, wenn du hochwischst, wird dir die Anwendung in den Hintergrund geschickt, bleibt aber quasi noch so inaktiv eingeschaltet.
Wenn du in Taskmanager gehst und das wegwischst, dann wird die Anwendung wirklich abgeschaltet.
Und manche Anwendungen, die die verwendet, die hat so eine komische Bücherei-App, die hängt sich ab und zu mal auf und geht dann nicht mehr.
Und da sage ich ja, du musst die App beenden und dann nochmal starten.
Und dann macht die immer, wischt die immer weg, dass die App in den Hintergrund geht und macht die wieder auf.
Und dann sagt sie, oh das geht nicht, kannst du mal gucken?
Ja, du musst in den Task Manager und die App beenden.
Wie geht denn das nochmal?
Also das ist...
Ja, nach How-To kann die das,
aber so verstehen tut sie es nicht.
So.
Haben wir schon mal Updates gemacht?
In letzter Zeit. Haben wir, aber es ist schon eine halbe Stunde her.
Das geht nicht.
Wie? Keine Updates?
Paket ist schon eine halbe Stunde alt.
So geht es aber nicht.
Updates muss ich auch machen.
Weil das ist aber gut.
Die traut sich immer nicht, irgendwelche Pop-Ups anzuklicken.
Was aber auch ganz gut ist.
Guck mal hier.
Hier gibt es noch Trennsymbole.
Hier gibt es keine Trennsymbole mehr.
Aber ich fühle mich trotzdem halbwegs zurecht.
So, Jetta, gucken wir uns mal an
Was trennt er denn auf GitHub diese Woche?
Lass uns mal merken
Der letzte Sellout war
So 50 Minuten im Stream
Mal gucken, wann der nächste Sellout kommt
Weil ich hab irgendwie den Eindruck, der kommt zu oft
So, GitHub
Trending weekly
Ne, ne, ne, nicht go
nicht go, sondern
über alles.
Hier, über alle
Programmiersprachen.
Sellout-Emote, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich brauche eh noch eine Liste für neue Emotes.
Emotes.txt
Wupp, Sellout.
Finde ich gut.
Wenn ihr übrigens gute Ideen für Emotes habt,
haut mal raus, ich habe noch so viele
Emote-Slots offen.
Da kann ich mal wieder was
commissionen.
Ich brauche, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall einen Wupp C++, wie auch immer das aussehen soll.
Also, was trennt er denn diese Woche auf GitHub?
Wupp Sport, Wupp Frankfurt
Das ist geil
Da machen wir ein Emote mit einer Spritze.
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Mit das Emote.
Wupp Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Sporn, weiß ich nicht.
Wir machen Wupp Hauptbahnhof.
Das ist dann irgendein Emote mit einer Spritze.
Das ist eine geile Idee.
Also, was trennt diese Woche auf GitHub?
Frankfurt mit Wolkenkratzer?
Das kann man schlechter als die Maut, glaube ich, machen.
Das ist so...
Man muss es ja auch erkennen, wenn es klein ist.
Irgendwie sowas
Wir können uns, also wenn ihr gute Ideen habt
Es wäre halt gut, wenn es Emotes sind
Die man auch regelmäßig anbringen kann
Wir brauchen jetzt keine 20 kompletten Nischen-Emotes
Wobei, also
Wupp, sehr laut finde ich guten Wupp
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof mit irgendeiner Spritze
Das ist eine gute Idee
So, als nächstes trennt
Was haben wir hier? Apple Container
Ja, was ist das denn eigentlich? Das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal
Die letzten Tage gelesen
Tool for creating and running Linux containers using lightweight virtual machines on a Mac.
Written in Swift, optimized for Apple Silicon.
Okay, also quasi der VM-Champ für Mac von Apple.
Syntax ist sehr Docker-like.
Finde ich gut, dass es sowas gibt.
Gibt es nicht auch sogar schon Docker für...
Gab es nicht Docker für Mac sogar?
Ja.
Vielleicht will...
Mal gucken, was daran besser ist.
Finde ich aber gut, weil MacOS ist jetzt schon eine deutlich angenehmere Plattform,
um darauf zu entwickeln und zu basteln als Windows.
einfach weil es die ganzen Linux Tools halt auch gibt.
Du merkst, da ist halt ein BSD drunter.
Also es ist Linux-artig genug, um nicht so sehr abzufacken wie Windows.
Und selbst Windows mit ESWSL ist halt eklig.
Es ist halt immer noch Windows.
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen einer Windows-Kiste...
Chat, was würdet ihr nehmen?
Wenn ihr euch entscheiden könntet, beispielsweise jetzt auf der Arbeit oder so,
zwischen einer Windows-Kiste mit WSL oder einem Mac.
Linux, sagen wir mal, Linux steht nicht zur Debatte, ja.
Ich würde immer einen Mac vorziehen.
Das ist einfach Linux-artig, also Unix-artig genug, dass es nicht abfuckt.
Ja, es gibt auf Mac auch ein bisschen was, was abfuckt.
Der Unterschied zwischen der Tastatur und sowas.
Aber unter Windows nervt mich einfach so sehr, dass es Windows ist.
Unter Mac kann ich wenigstens meine Shell aufmachen und habe da eine Umgebung, die sehr ähnlich ist zu einer Linux-Kiste.
Früher hat man ja unter macOS mit Homebrew-Sachen nachinstalliert.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe in letzter Zeit vermehrt gelesen, dass Homebrew out ist und jetzt irgendwas anderes angesagt ist.
Hat da jemand Ahnung von euch, was das war?
Kann mich nämlich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Irgendwas, irgendwas, was nicht Homebrew ist.
Homemanager? Das kann sein.
Wobei ist Homemanager nicht...
Macports! Das könnte es sein, ja.
Ist Homemanager nicht die Nix-Geschichte?
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Also Apple Container.
AI.
Microsoft markt darstellen desktop app to manage markt knowledge bases was ist das
nicht
das kenne ich haben wir auch ein cv nicht sogar schon mal verwendet on stream für image detection
Irgendwas war da nochmal
Ich glaube, wir haben das
Onstream schon mal
Wir haben mal
Object Detection in Bildern
Gemacht
So testweise
Ich glaube, das war mit OpenCV
Ich könnte auch mit YOLO gewesen sein
Für deinen Wasserzähler
Ne, für
Das Hoftor
AI, AI
Nein, doch.
Dann lass uns doch gerade mal hier gucken.
Was ist Tolaria?
Es ist eine ganz normale
Note-Taking-
Application?
Oder?
Von denen es Tausende gibt,
die gefühlt auch alle so aussehen?
Da gibt es hunderte von
Und warum
Und warum jetzt ausgerechnet das
Es ist written in Rust würde ich sagen
Oder?
Wenn ich da Tauri und so schon sehe
Ne, Timescript
Ah ja doch, teilweise
Das Frontend ist written in Rust
Wahrscheinlich ist es deswegen so beliebt.
Ah, keine Ahnung.
OpenCV.
So, das will ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Ich will mir nur noch eine Sache mal angucken.
Und zwar, wie hässlich
C++ ist. Wir müssen jetzt einmal kurz noch...
Guck mal, Leute.
Ich bin schon zu dumm, in diesem
Repo, Modules
wahrscheinlich, den Source-Code
zu finden. Wisst ihr, ich würde
auch gerne Obsidian verwenden.
Was ich echt gerne bei Obsidian hätte,
ist, dass man
Notifications einfügen kann,
die auf mobilen Geräten
funktionieren. Dann wäre das
für mich Premium.
Also ich beispielsweise ein To-Do in Obsidian
machen kann, irgendwo rein und sagen, ey, erinnere mich
daran am
15.6.13 Uhr.
Alter, ich checke nicht mal,
wo ist denn hier der Source-Code überhaupt?
Okay, hier
Pass auf, super hübscher C++ Source Code jetzt
Bam
Yes
Wisst ihr, das ist ordentlicher C++ Source Code
Aber sogar das
Sieht schon einfach so eklig
Und scheiße und hässlich aus
Das kann man
C++ ist
Sehr schlecht passbar
Mit dem Auge einfach nur
Und das ist noch hübscher, das geht noch voll klar
Das ist doch hübscher, C++-Sourcecode, ja?
Ach, sowas hier.
Ey, ich sage, es geht noch.
Aber sogar das, was geht, ist halt hässlich as fuck.
Das geht und es geht voll klar, ja?
Viel hübscher kannst du C++ nicht programmieren.
Aber sogar das ist schon eklig.
Alfred, den findest du toll, gell?
Den Standard Back Inserter.
Wer das nicht checkt, was der Alfred da im Chat geschrieben hat.
Standard Back Inserter.
Ich zeige euch nochmal richtig, richtig abartige C++ Syntax.
Also, ne.
in
in normalen
Programmiersprachen, ja, kannst du zum Beispiel
sowas machen. Wir machen das mal so Pseudo-Code
mäßig, ja. Du kannst
sowas hier machen.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
Filter
x größer 2
oder so. Sowas kannst du machen.
Dann kriegst du ein neues Array
raus, was
hier war, blubb gleich,
so nach dem Motto, ja. Kriegst du ein neues
Array raus, was alles Kurser 2 enthält. In C++
selbstverständlich geht es nicht so
einfach. Da musst du dann sowas
hier machen.
Whatever.
Ich möchte schon sehen.
Guck, da musst du dann sagen,
Ey, das ist so hässlich, Alter
Standard Copy
Von Beginn zu Ende
Und dann Back Inserter
Da wieder rein
Es ist so eklig, Alter
Und wenn ich das hier schon sehe, drehe ich auch immer durch
Wobei man das ja mittlerweile gar nicht braucht
Jaja, es gibt 100 Möglichkeiten
Das braucht man doch gar nicht
Mittlerweile hat doch C++ auch eine Range Loop, oder?
Die ganz brauchbar funktioniert
Ja genau, hier das da
Also eines der wenigen Sachen, die ich ganz hübsch finde
Von der Syntax her
Also, bin ich die einzige
Okay, genug C++ Flames
Weil ansonsten geht das wieder vom Hundertsten ins Tausendste
Und ich sitze hier eine halbe Stunde und flame über C++
Obsidian
Ja, aber die Plugins funktionieren meistens nur auf dem Desktop, oder?
ja nicht rum hier was das tag das von so nur auf dem desktop oder
plugin ford nord alert mobile
also auch wenn der plugin request mobile app to create delivery
notifizierst du brauchst die du brauchst die not alert app brauchst du
das heißt nicht dass du also gibt es nicht für ios außerdem heißt es nicht dass es auch
für mobile obsidian funktioniert da gibt es nichts dass das wäre echt geil ich habe
auch nichts gefunden weil ich geil wenn das funktioniert
So, weiter
Was trennt ihr denn sonst noch so auf GitHub?
Guck mal was man sich scharf trennt
Das kann man nicht so einfach machen
Wenn das einfach
Wir hätten das schon heute gemacht
das ist das die mobile
also die
Obsidian API gibt das irgendwie nicht her
da gibt es sogar einen hier
Obsidian Mobile Notifications
da gibt es sogar einen Feature Request
bei Obsidian
der ist schon ewig offen
und das juckt die nicht
ist github.com
wipecoded
das ist Microsoft
sehr sicher sind davon einige Teile mittlerweile
wipecoded
Ist hier das Funds nicht richtig?
Da gibt es doch irgendwo so ein Feature Request bei.
Okay, also was trennt man?
Das kennen wir, das kennen wir, das kennen wir.
Immer noch mein Lieblings-Backend-Framework.
Auf der Arbeit mache ich das meiste mittlerweile in Go.
Wenn es da ein bisschen was zu Proggers gibt, zu Proggen gibt, weil Go-Binaries halt einfach so schön portable sind.
.NET, IoT-Binaries sind auch ganz gut portable, aber nix schlägt Go, was das angeht.
Self-Contained-Binaries, die einfach überall laufen.
Kennst du das Uptime? Ja, das kenn ich. Das haben wir uns auch schon im Stream angeguckt.
hier, Uptime von GitHub
vor und nach Microsoft
Kauf von GitHub
es gibt ja auch
diese GitHub Status
Page, nicht die
offizielle GitHub Status Page, sondern
hier die da, weil die hier
kannst du vergessen, die hier, guck mal
87% Uptime
87%
Leute
Die hätten uns alle schon rausgeschmissen
Hätten wir 87% Uptime
Wir wären alle weg
Sag ich euch
Instant
Wir hätten uns alle rausgeschmissen
Bei 87% Uptime
Was bei uns teilweise Minuten an Ausfällen kostet
Ist schon nicht normal
Aber wir haben gesehen, auch GitLab ist nicht sicher vor den...
Wie nennen wir es? Vor den Schergen von Microsoft.
Weil GitLab hat letztens auch auf Verlangen von, also vermutet man zumindest, das ist ja nicht offiziell,
offiziell
vermutlich auf das Verlangen
von Microsoft hin Leute gesperrt.
Also hat GitLab
durchaus, oder sagen wir so, hat Microsoft
wohl durchaus auch Einfluss auf GitLab.
Ja, aber das ist halt, also ich meine, 87%
ist halt der Witz, ja.
Ich glaube, die programmieren nur noch mit dem Fanatec Headshot Controller.
Dich nervt, dass GitHub kein IPv6 kann?
Ist es nicht so, dass sogar Amazon auch kein IPv6 kann?
Habt ihr SpaceX Aktien gekauft?
Nee.
Aber ich habe das ein bisschen verfolgt.
Prinzip so wie am Anfang.
Wird bei euch auch AI-Vibe-Coding auf der Arbeit als Lösung für...
Nein, glücklicherweise nicht.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das wird bei uns nicht als Lösung für alles gepusht.
Liegt vielleicht daran, dass wir Teamleiter und sogar Abteilungsleiter haben,
die ein bisschen Ahnung von Technik haben.
Also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass bei uns auf der Arbeit auch einiges mittlerweile vibe-coded ist.
Letztens zum Beispiel was gefunden.
So sinngemäß...
Hier, es war...
Cat, etc, passwd...
Quad, delimiter...
Blah, so.
Also, etc, passwd...
Guck, da kannst du dir hier irgendwas rausketten.
Du kannst hier genau Login Shell.
Ja, also es war quasi sowas in der Richtung.
Also ich habe letztens in dem Skript auf der Arbeit stand sinngemäß sowas drin.
Hier, Cut, Delimiter am Doppelpunkt Field 7.
Genau.
Und das gibt die Login Shell vom jeweiligen User raus.
und wir haben bei uns im Hintergrund so ein, ich nenne das mal Compliance Scanner laufen,
der guckt, ob die Systeme den offiziellen unternehmensweiten Vorgaben entsprechen.
Und es gibt für bestimmte User die Vorgabe, dass die keine Login-Shell haben dürfen.
Zum Beispiel für Grafana zum Beispiel.
Der Grafana User darf keine Login Shell haben
Und solche Geschichten
Und die haben dann so einen Scanner im Hintergrund
Das ist was selbstgestricktes
Komplett historisch gewachsen
Seit 30 Jahren oder so
War sogar mal irgendwann lauffähig noch auf Solaris
Und wahrscheinlich lief das teilweise
Auch mal auf Mainframe oder so
Das ist auch nicht Bash
Das ist auch noch Cornshell
Also könnt ihr euch vorstellen wie alt das ist
Und da haben sie
Gevibe Coded
nämlich meine systeme wurden angemeckert mein grafana user hat angeblich eine login shell so
und da haben sie folgendes gevibe codet anstatt das hier und ich weiß am comet dass das gevibe
codet war ja anstatt das hier zu vibe coden wie ein paar zeilen oben drüber hat die ki das hier
vibe coded und das funktioniert halt nicht bei jedem user schon ziemlich dumm
oder und da war halt mein system und mein user dabei wo halt raus kam es ist
eine andere login shell gesetzt an und weil er nichts gefunden hat und da
muss man dann davon hand rein und dann doppelpunkt raus machen
hat die KI halt Mist-Vibe-Code
und es wurde einfach committed, ohne sich Gedanken zuzumachen.
Aber glücklicherweise preist es bei uns,
also zumindest habe ich das noch nie mitbekommen,
keiner an,
dass Vibe-Coding die Lösung für alles ist.
Aber wir haben einiges wipecoded mittlerweile.
Genau, die Lösung für
schlechtes Wipecoding ist einfach mehr Wipecoding.
Alles nur noch
egentic.
Also Nvidia sieht das übrigens
auch so, weil wir wissen ja,
Tokens, Leute.
Tokens sind Revenue.
Tokens.
Und ein Software-Engineer für 500.000 Euro ist auf einmal so effektiv wie drei Software-Engineers für 500.000 Euro.
Weil Tokens sind Revenue. Profit, Leute. Profit.
Tokens gleich Profit.
Oder irgendwie sowas hat er uns das letzte Mal erzählt.
Ja, das ist für mich, das hat gar nicht so die große Runde gemacht, aber für mich ist das eines der bezeichnendsten Sachen, was so technikmäßig verkehrt läuft in letzter Zeit.
Ich werde das nochmal kurz erzählen, weil wie gesagt, es hat nicht so die große Runde gemacht. Amazon hatte ein internes Ranking und zwar ein internes Ranking für Token Usage bei Entwicklern.
Also wenn du viel AI benutzt, verbreitst du auch viele Tokens
Tokens sind quasi die kleinsten Einheiten von Wortschnipseln, mit denen KI funktioniert
Und die hatten quasi ein internes Token Ranking, was quasi ein Ranking ist, wer wie viel KI benutzt
So und dieses Ranking bei Amazon, dieses interne, wer benutzt die meiste AI Ranking, war wohl recht präzisträchtig
und die Leute hatten auch den Eindruck,
das kommt bei der nächsten Gehaltsverhandlung
und Beförderungssache mit auf den Tisch.
Und was haben die Leute gemacht?
Logischerweise haben sie der KI
komplett sinnlose Aufträge gegeben,
den ganzen Tag,
damit ihre Talken-Usage da oben schnellt.
Und da war das Management auf einmal ganz furchtbar überrascht,
so hoch, surprised Pikachu-Face.
Wir haben ein Ranking
und die Leute faken das Ranking.
Wie kann dann das sein?
Und dann haben sie das Ranking
wieder abgeschafft.
Da gibt es ein gutes Video zu. Okay, gucken wir uns mal an.
Wie kriege ich
diesen dummen
KDE Wallet Service weg?
Genau so muss das Famazon gewesen sein.
Um 1 Trillion Token zu sparen.
Okay, wir können nicht 1 Trillion Token sparen.
Wir haben es verfehlt.
Wir werden in Quote-Limit geraten.
Token, Token, Token, Token, Token.
Ja, so ungefähr stelle ich mir das bei Amazon vor, dass es da so abgelaufen sein muss.
Und das ist genau das, was dem Nvidia-Chef auch gefällt.
Ich kann das nicht. Ich kann das nicht.
Ja, so stelle ich mir das vor, genau so.
Genau, exzellent
Guck dir mal meinen Reflink an, sehr gute Wahl
Und ich muss ja auch
Betonen an der Stelle nochmal
Das ist den Anbietern
Ganz wichtig
Dass es die günstigen Preise nur über
Meinen Reflink gibt
Und nicht so bei Alternate oder so
Einfach immer über meinen Reflink gehen
Settings, KDE Passwort Save,
Untick KDE Passwort Save, Activate.
Okay.
Passwort Save.
Ah ne, oh, das hässliche Ding muss ich
aninstallen.
Äh, wo finde ich das?
Was? Okay, Settings.
Okay, siehst du, ich vertraue dem Chat
mal, dass der Chat weiß, was Sache ist.
Passwort Save.
Hier Wallet wahrscheinlich.
Enable KDE Wallet Subsystem
Disable, bam
Ja, ja, geh weg
Zack
Wollen wir den Sound wieder leiser
So, jetzt haben wir es disabled
Ja, gucken wir mal weiter
Was auf GitHub gerade läuft, ach ja
By the way, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Wo wir gerade Sellout hatten
Sellout müsste ja auch demnächst im Chat wieder
Popup laufen
ich muss ja einmal pro stream das ganze vorstellen wenn ihr gerade überlegt euch
das zuzulegen oder vielleicht anwendungszwecke für das habt oder neue
festplatten kaufen wollt dann kann ich empfehlen geht mal auf mein profil oder
guckte mal im chat ausrufezeichen ukraine ausrufezeichen sie geht
ausrufezeichen alternate und dann landet ihr hier bei alternate auf der webseite
da seht ihr die ganzen angebote die sind wirklich günstig und gibt es auch nur
über meinen refflink und da könnt ihr euch mal das ganze angucken was es gibt
es gibt neben festplatten gibt es tatsächlich relativ günstige und vor
allem preis nicht preis für stromsparende nassgeräte die für den
heimbereich voll und ganz ausreichen da könnt ihr euch zum beispiel mal das
kleine ukrain nass angucken oder das ein bisschen größere ukrain nass das ist
2-Bay-NAS, also perfekt für einen Raid 1 oder sowas.
Ihr kriegt ja auch ein relativ günstiges Bundle.
Einsteiger-U-Crew-NAS plus 2x6 TB Seagate Ironwolf-NAS-Festplatten.
Also die sind auf 24-7 Betrieb ausgelegt.
Und das NAS ist leistungsmäßig für den Preis auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Wenn man sich das nämlich anguckt, da sehen wir,
hier ist ein bisschen
älterer, dafür
stromsparender Quad-Core drin
das Ding hat glaube ich 4 Efficiency-Cores
nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle
ihr bekommt 8 GB RAM, allein schon der RAM ist ja
mittlerweile fast zu viel für die Kiste
2,5 GB Ethernet
also damit könnt
ihr, das Ding hat nämlich auch Hardware-Encryption
damit kriegt ihr beispielsweise
wenn ihr da Linux drauf
installiert, die Festplatten verschlüsselt mit Lux
und RAID 1 drüber macht oder sowas in der Richtung
oder ihr installiert Unraid drauf oder Proxmox drauf oder sowas,
dann oder ob MediaVault oder sowas,
ihr könnt natürlich auch das offizielle Ukraine OS benutzen,
dann kriegt ihr relativ sicher, behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal,
diesen 2,5 Gig Link Saturated.
Und das ist preis-leistungsmäßig wirklich nice.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, und im Endeffekt ist es relativ einfach.
Sucht ihr euch raus, was ihr haben wollt.
Klickt das an.
Und Warenkorb.
Ab geht's bei Alternate.
Alternate ist auch ein guter Shop.
Ich habe schon oftmals Sachen bestellt.
Ich muss sagen, Alternate
hatte ich tatsächlich einmal wirklich ein gutes Erlebnis.
Kann ich mich auch richtig dran erinnern.
Ich habe mal ein Gehäuse bestellt.
Kurz nachdem ich umgezogen bin,
habe ich ein Gehäuse bei Alternate bestellt
und habe es an die falsche Adresse bestellt.
Habe ich damals da angerufen
und die haben gesagt, gar kein Problem.
Bestellen sie das Gehäuse einfach nochmal
und wir schreiben das Alte,
sobald es quasi nicht angenommen wird,
automatisch wieder gut.
Hat auch sofort funktioniert.
Also ich habe bisher immer nur gute Erfahrungen
bei Alternate gemacht. Einmal eine richtig gute.
Sellout beendet.
Gucken wir mal weiter, was auf GitHub so trendet.
Das muss ich mir aufschreiben, Leute.
Sellout.
Sellout TXT.
Wir sind 1.24
im Stream.
Am
14.06.
2026 aufwachen.
Sellout TXT.
Ich muss das.
Wir wollen ja bestimmt
irgendeine Auswertung danach haben.
Kann das Video
transkodiert für Linux ISO Streams?
Das gucken wir mal. Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ob das Quick Sync hat.
Gucken wir mal.
Äh.
Moment.
Bin grad zu.
Zu blöd.
Hat das Quick Sync.
Das müssen wir mal schauen.
Was für eine CPU haben wir denn?
Die da.
Vielleicht sehen wir hier schon irgendwas.
Was mit Video gedöhnt.
Okay, blub blub blub blub blub.
Blub blub blub blub blub.
Haben wir hier irgendwo eine technische Daten?
Sieht man jetzt nicht.
Dann müssen wir mal kurz schauen, ob der Quick Sync hat.
Ja, eignet sich sogar für Videotranscoding.
Dafür ist es echt günstig.
Videotranscoding, Hardware Encryption, das ist ziemlich nice.
Hast du auch 4-Bay-Ness im Angebot?
Aktuell nicht, aber soll ich mal fragen,
ob es auch 4-Bay-Nesses gibt?
Vielleicht können die auch noch 4-Bay-Nesses anbieten.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, das Angebot ist fix,
aber ich kann die mal fragen,
ob es auch 4-Bay-Nesses gibt.
sind die nassfestplatten irgendwie speziell kann man die auch so für den normalen rechner
hernehmen oder ist das overkill underkill die kannst du auch für normalen rechner nehmen der
reinen lehre nach ist der unterschied folgendermaßen nassfestplatten sind für 24 7 betrieb ausgelegt
Desktop-Festplatten sind darauf ausgelegt, dass sie auch öfters mal angefahren und runtergefahren werden können.
Also du hast theoretisch mit einer NAS-Festplatte im Desktop-Betrieb eine etwas geringere Lebensdauer als im NAS und umgedreht.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass das nennenswert irgendeine Auswirkung hat.
Die reden ja hier nicht von 1000 Start-Stop-Zyklen am Tag oder sowas.
die kannst du also auch ohne probleme desktop verwenden bis jetzt nicht
soll ich aber das lustige erzählen habe ich im letzten stream schon erzählt
Ich fand das einfach wieder typisch Wubblos-Chat.
Ich fand das irgendwie witzig.
Ich habe letzten Montag, bevor ich gestreamt habe,
habe ich dieses Banner hier schon reingemacht.
Und am Dienstag haben die sich beschwert bei mir per Mail,
dass es schon 2000 Klicks auf dieses Banner gegeben hat,
obwohl ich nicht gestreamt habe.
Da hat irgendeiner mein Refling-View bottet am Montag.
Ich hatte ja den RF-Programmer im Verdacht,
Aber da sagt er war es nicht.
The fuck?
Ja, ich glaub dir, dass es nicht war.
Leute, jetzt hab ich...
Moment, ich hab die GitHub-Trends zugemacht.
Das wollte ich auch gar nicht.
Ich wollte noch gucken, was...
Bei C-Sharp-Tenet.
Hast du das mitbekommen?
Ja, da habe ich mich schon bestimmt eine halbe Stunde
im Stream am Anfang drüber ausgelassen.
Aua, Packages.
Also, das kennen wir, das kennen wir, das kennen wir.
Bla, blub.
Unity, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht.
Juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht.
AI.
Juck mich nicht.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Keine Ahnung.
Avalonia.
Gut für Cross-Plattform-Dotnet-Anwendungen.
Das einzige Sinnvolle für Cross-Plattform-Dotnet-Anwendungen.
Müssen wir jetzt nicht von Maui oder irgendeinem Schrott anfangen.
Clean Architecture.
Ganz ehrlich.
das war ja eine zeit lang im dotnet ökosystem total gehypt was das
optimizer da war das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt da kannst du irgendwelche
windows sachen irgendwelche windows settings mit ändern kann das gleiche
banken das war ja dieses ding hier war ja im dotnet ökosystem jahrelang super
gehypt haben alle gesagt wir müssen clean architecture machen und irgendwie
1000 unterprojekte und 1000 interfaces und so ich habe mir damals schon immer
an den kopf gegriffen haben gesagt leute übertreibt es nicht und irgendwann
habe ich mal ein Tutorial-Video gesehen zu
Clean Architecture und da hat jemand
wirklich ernsthaft
anstatt einfach DateTime zu
verwenden aus .NET, also
aus dem .NET Framework,
hat der eine, ein DateTime
Interface angelegt
und die ganzen DateTime Methoden gerappt,
falls man mal eine andere
DateTime Implementierung nimmt.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, Leute,
man kann
auch im Vorfeld
für alle Eventualitäten irgendwas machen
und fünfmal so lange brauchen, bis man was entwickelt hat.
Das übertreibt es halt mal.
Mittlerweile ist der Trend davon schon ein bisschen weggegangen.
Der aktuelle Trend im .NET Ökosystem, was so Web-Backends angeht,
ist ja, dass man es eher Feature-basiert macht.
Also sprich, man hat ein Feature wie zum Beispiel Profile, Profile-Page oder sowas.
Und dafür hat man dann einen eigenen Ordner, Features, Profile-Page.
und da ist dann quasi das
Profile-Page-Frontend-Template,
der Profile-Page-Service,
Profile-Page-Wrapper
für irgendwas und so drinnen.
Das finde ich eigentlich eine ganz sinnvolle Sache.
Endlich auch der Time-Provider-Single-Factory.
Aber,
also ich glaube,
das Bescheuertste, was ich jemals,
ich finde diesen Webcast
leider nicht mehr. Das war irgendeine
Ruby-Veranstaltung,
Single Line
Line Coat Smell
Das war
Irgendeine Ruby Veranstaltung
War das der Dude
Hier vor 8 Jahren
Kommt doch hin
War das der Dude
Ich erkenne das Video sofort wieder
Wenn ich den höre
Ne
Ne ne
Ne ne das war es nicht
Zumindest...
Was ist da vielleicht?
13 Jahre her? Das war, als ich noch viel
Hubi-Sachen programmiert habe. Das könnte
es tatsächlich gewesen sein.
Aber zumindest...
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht zusammen an.
Wieso kann man bei Tests nicht einfach
Daytime verwenden? Ich meine,
Daytime ist in jedem .NET-Kram drin.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist für Testing gemacht,
aber man kann es auch übertreiben.
Hallo, YouTube.
The true reason C++ always wins.
Okay, also YouTube hat keinen Bock.
Sagt, geht nicht.
Zumindest, ich glaube, das ist dieser Talk.
Ich will mir den jetzt nicht mit euch angucken.
Ich will nur eine Sache sagen,
wo ich mal wirklich der sinnloseste Advice aller Zeiten
Ja, also
Das könnte sogar
Dieser Talk gewesen sein
Zumindest
Hat
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das sogar
Dieser Presenter war
Da habe ich mal vor 10 Jahren
So einen Ruby Talk gesehen
Und er hat sich darüber ausgelassen
So typische Code Smells
In Ruby Code
und dann hat er so eine Frage gestellt
in die
zum Publikum
in die Menge rein
hat er gesagt, ab wie vielen Zeilen Code
von einer Methode
meint ihr, ist das für ihn
ein Codesmell
und da habe ich mir so gedacht
ja, keine Ahnung, sobald es halt länger als
eine Seite ist, so irgendwie so 50
Zeilen oder so und dann meinte der
in diesem Video, more than a single
line
Da hab ich mir gedacht, Alter, das ist ja der bescheuertste
Advice, den ich jemals gehört hab
Jede Methode, die
Mehr als eine Zeile Code enthält, ist
Codesmell, ja, alles klar
Wie sieht es dann aus? Besteht dann sein
Source-Code quasi nur noch zu
90% aus Methoden- oder
Funktionen-Definitionen oder was?
Wie soll das funktionieren, Alter?
Wie soll ich Logik umsetzen, wenn ich nicht
Mehr als eine Zeile Methode haben kann?
Total, mir
Das war so der Zeitpunkt
Ich habe ja früher so Konferenztalks und so, habe ich ja verschlungen und alles immer komplett für bare Münze genommen.
Und das war so der Punkt, wo ich einen Konferenztalk gesehen habe und da ist mir zum ersten Mal klar geworden, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Die haben auch nicht die Weisheit mit Löffel gefressen.
Du musst das auch mal ein bisschen hinterfragen, was auf solchen Konferenztalks erzählt wird, ob das für dich sinnvoll ist.
Und mittlerweile gibt es schon einige dinger wo ich mir das anhöre auf irgendwelche konferenz talks und mir so denke
Es auch echt kompliziert machen bei manchen konferenz talks habe ich so den eindruck
Der labert nur darüber dass das geil ist dass er mit talk drüber machen kann eigentlich ist es komplett sinnlos
Egal
Gucken wir uns mal weiter an.
Optimizer Duck.
Free Open Source Windows Optimation Tool
für Performance, Privacy und Simplicity.
Guck, da kannst du hier so Sachen mit optimieren.
Prioritize Active Applications.
Optimize Multimedia Scannable.
Disable Backup.
Kannst du hier irgendwelche Windows Sachen setzen.
Also sowas.
Rüya TuneUp Utility 96 und so war.
Gibt es heute.
Optimize Duck.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich wirklich sinnvolle Dinge
auch drin hat. Nicht so
so Scareware-mäßig.
So, das ist hier China-Chinesen-Zeug. Was ist das?
PCL.
Ist PCL nicht, nicht, nicht diese
IBM
Mainframe-Geschichte?
Ne.
War das nicht auf Mainframe?
Ist das nicht Mainframe? Auch PCL?
Okay, dann bring ich es vielleicht
durcheinander.
Planecraft-Launcher 2.
ok china chinesen solcher um keine ahnung was es ist chatbot haben das
removing aber perfekt so weg also keine ahnung was es ist es ist china chinesen
zeug wenn er etwas von kraft drin steht ist es wahrscheinlich in minecraft zeug
besetzen wir mal ja wollte ich gerade machen es geht damit chrome besser und
jetzt geht es nicht mehr weil ich den sach bloß chrome geht nicht mehr weil
ich den KDE Wallet Service ausgeschaltet
habe.
Ich kriege Anfälle.
Settings.
Wallet.
Okay, es ist jetzt
mein Chrome komplett. Ach ne, da ist das Wallet.
Da ist das Wallet.
Ich gebe einfach das Passwort ein, gut ist.
So. Ach ja, Englisch gibt es doch auch.
Ich muss das gar nicht im Chrome übersetzen.
Is a community edition developed as a secondary project based on PCL.
Was zum Teufel ist PCL?
Die tun so ein...
Planecraft Launcher.
Programming, das ist sogar ein .NET Programm.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was Planecraft Launcher sein soll.
Minecraft All-in-One-Solution.
Okay, doch Minecraft.
Alright.
Minecraft.
Haben wir heute eigentlich schon
rebooted? Ich glaube nicht.
So, was
trendet denn bei Rust?
Lass uns mal gucken, was Rust
trendet.
Goose, kennen wir.
AI. Nicht AI.
Kann Bio
mittlerweile ordentlich mit
Welt umgehen?
Die hatten da noch Probleme. Das müssen wir jetzt gerade mal gucken.
Gucken, dieses Language Support.
Das Feld ist immer noch nicht richtig supported.
Experimental. Immerhin, vielleicht geht es ja mittlerweile.
Zumindest hatten die eine Zeit lang das Problem, dass die zwar das JavaScript formatieren konnten, aber nicht das HTML und sowas. Ganz weird, Champ.
Ich meine, immerhin können sie mittlerweile JavaScript, HTML und CSS.
Das ist ein Formatter für Webgedöns.
Ist MainStack able to format linte...
Okay, gut.
Okay, es funktioniert alles richtig.
Ah ja.
Jetzt knicken.
Äh, was?
Mit JS macht man ja meist das DOM selbst.
Gibt es eigentlich schon welche, die das quasi mit Wasm machen?
Und verstehe ich das?
Äh, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so ganz, was du meinst.
Also, Wasm hat kein DOM-Access.
Du kannst mit Wasm keine Webseite manipulieren.
Oder was meinst du jetzt genau?
ne ne ne das geht nicht
also du kannst mit Wasm nur
die Webseite manipulieren
wenn du
wiederum quasi einen Call machst
Richtung JavaScript
also so Sachen wie Blazor im Browser
zum Beispiel, also es gibt ja
zum Beispiel hier
Ihr Blazer von Microsoft
Das ist quasi
.NET Razer Pages
Als Wasm für den Browser
Und wenn die
Da HTML Zeug machen
Rate ich jetzt
Ich hab mir das nie im Detail angeguckt
Aber anders geht es meines Wissens da nicht
Müssen die zu JavaScript callen
Die benutzt nur Wasm, dass die Sharp im Browser läuft
Das ist ein Projekt,
wo ich ehrlich gesagt
die Daseinsberechtigung
nur zum Teil verstehe.
Gibt es wirklich irgendjemand, der schon mal gesagt hat,
ah, also
Cat,
das sollte mal in Rust rewritet werden.
Oder Cat oder so.
Also hier Cat und Cat und Cat, das musste unbedingt in Rust rewritten werden.
Unbedingt.
Das geht nicht ohne.
Ohne Rust rewrite.
Aber ich meine, so den Inhalt von einer Datei ausgeben, das ist einfach nicht gut, wenn es nicht written in Rust ist.
Also ich weiß nicht, hat sich das jemals schon mal jemand gedacht?
Den Sinn davon verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Und jetzt, ja, ich weiß, jetzt kommen die Leute, aber Security, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass die Coriolatils 40 Jahre Battle-Tested-Code enthalten und die Rust-Geschichte nicht.
und Rust hilft zwar
gegen typische
C-Geschichten, ja, also so nach dem Motto
Variable
gefreed und danach drauf zugegriffen
oder out of bounds checks von Eraser
hilft Rust dagegen
gegen
Fail in der Programmierlogik
hilft Rust aber nicht
Gibt es da jetzt eigentlich eine Liste, was da mittlerweile
alles für Tools drin sind.
Guck mal. Oder
Base64-Encoding. Hat sich
schon irgendjemand mal gedacht, oh ja,
also Echo
muss in Rust rewritet werden
und Base64-Encoding von
Echo 1. Schade, dass
das nicht in Rust geschrieben ist.
Zumal die jetzt eher Probleme haben, dass die
nicht hundertprozentig featuregleich sind
und jetzt irgendwelche Skripte fehlen. Also ich bin mal
gespannt, wie das beim nächsten Ubuntu
aussieht. Oder kam das jetzt nicht raus?
Hat nicht das aktuelle Ubuntu 26.04 schon das hier als Core-Utils?
Also das verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Also ich verstehe, warum man es macht.
Macht bestimmt Spaß.
Ob man es braucht?
Ich weiß ja nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Er hält sich auch irgendwie sehr in Grenzen, oder?
Wo bleibt Wappenwupps sehr laut?
Keine Ahnung.
wir hatten es doch eben wo ich wo ich den webseiten sellout gemacht habe
aber hier leute wenn ihr unbedingt mal den sellout noch mal sehen wollt sekunde massive sellout
Bam
Da ist er
Da habt ihr ihn
Huge Sellout
Ich habe jetzt manuell mal gestartet
Massive
Link im Banner
So sieht es aus
So, was trennen denn sonst noch
paar Rusts?
Oh, jetzt haben wir Ox.
Was können die eigentlich
mittlerweile alles?
Die wollen ja auch
das komplette
JavaScript-Ökosystem rewriten
in Rust.
Was können die mittlerweile alles?
Okay, die haben einen Linter,
einen Formatter,
das ist Konkurrenz
zu Biom,
Biom kann denn
OxFMT so Sachen wie
Svelte mittlerweile schon?
Weil das ist halt das Ding,
es lassen sich sehr einfach neue Projekte
starten, so nach dem Motto
Rewritten in Rust, bla, sonst was.
Problem ist dann nur,
dass die Dinger dann
relativ schnell bei 80%
angekommen sind, aber du brauchst
ja das, was die bisherigen Tools können
auch und dann wartest du Jahre auf die
20%. Okay, supported include
Svelte,
Okay, Compatibility Syntax
Hier, Svelte
No Template Linting yet
Na super, unusable aktuell noch
Wenn du kein Template Linting hast
Template Linting heißt
Das kann HTML nicht formatieren
In Svelte Komponenten
Kannst du also vergessen
Ach Moment, Linting, sorry, ich hab mich verguckt
Formatting
Ich hab mich verguckt, Linting interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
das geht das ist mal an der zeit ist auszuprobieren würde ich sagen
ok was trennen sonst noch das haben wir schon gesehen network monitor für linux
MXC-Liste, die wird das, die ist
Append-Only.
Agent-Gateway?
Agent, Alter. Agent.
Agent, Leute. Agent-Gateway.
Policy-Driven-Layer-Isolation
and Containment. Was?
Alter! Können die mal
bitte Produktbeschreibung machen, wo man
versteht, was damit gemeint ist?
Okay, ich gehe davon aus, es ist irgendwelche
KI-Geschichte. Chat, wenn ihr das
hier lest, Policy-Driven-Layer-
isolation and containment. Habt ihr irgendwie
eine Ahnung, was das für ein Projekt sein soll?
Ich weiß, ihr werdet jetzt sagen,
ob, wie ist die logisch, Max?
He lacks critical information. Keck, laugh.
Aber versteht
jemand legit,
was das hier sein soll
anhand der Projektbeschreibung?
A sandboxed code execution system
for running untrusted code.
Model Output, Plugins, Tools on Windows.
Also ist das das, was man
im AI-Buzzword-Junkong aktuell
Harness nennt, oder was?
Es ist Blazingly Fast.
Das haben die hier gar nicht reingeschrieben.
Es ist ja auch nicht written in Rust,
es ist ja wipecoded in Rust.
Wollen wir gucken,
ob es wipecoded in Rust ist.
LXC? WXC?
Ach so!
Das ist quasi LXC
für Windows, oder was?
Okay, dann ist es doch was anderes.
Erst kam Apple mit Apple-Containern
um die Ecke und jetzt kommen die mir damit?
What the fuck?
Was bin ich hier sehen?
Stimmt, war abcoded.
So, was trennt ihr denn sonst noch?
AI?
Rust-Based Platform for the Web.
SWC.
Und was soll das jetzt bedeuten?
Ist vier Jahre alt, okay.
Make the web...
Make web development faster.
JavaScript TypeScript Compiler written in Rust.
Aha.
Okay.
Kann man vielleicht irgendwann mal gebrauchen?
falls man irgendwann mal wirklich was in javascript oder teilschrift programmieren
muss an tools für linux server die man dann vielleicht zu einem single binary
kommt aber naja es nimmt ruf extrem die fast peter linter ich finde das witzig
dass so viel tooling für andere programmier sprachen mittlerweile
einen ritten den raster web framework als terry nas production grade linux alter
im leben im leben bestimmt weib coded
Eine Linux-Alterative in Rust, die, wenn man Glück hat, vielleicht in der VM bootet.
Als wäre es so easy, mal eine Linux-Alterative zu erstellen.
Das ist bestimmt...
Die ganzen Kommentare und so, das ist bestimmt vibe-coded.
Vielleicht tue ich denen auch Unrecht.
So, und als letztes gucken wir, was in Gold rendet.
Da gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an.
Ja, genau.
Genau, genau.
So stelle ich mir das auch vor, ja.
Ne, die wurde noch nicht angesprochen.
Aber da gab es letztens...
Was war das? Ich habe das gelesen.
Irgendwas, was sie Bumsrakete genannt haben.
Genau. FreeBSD war das.
Das ist...
Chat, wir suchen jetzt mal nach Bumsrakete.
Und ich...
Und das ist kein NSFW.
Achtung.
Hier.
Kernelbug.
FreeBSD Exploit.
Bumsrakete
verleiht Ruhtzugriff.
Das habe ich letztens schon gelesen, ja.
Also das ist doch mal
ein guter Name
für eine Sicherheitslücke, oder?
Nicht so Zeug,
Hardbleed, Copyfail
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Nein, Bumsrakete alles.
Das ist doch mal ein Name dafür.
3 psd page cash erinnert mich ein bisschen an copy fail oder die
bums rakete gefährdet systeme auf basis von freebsd
Das erinnert ein bisschen an Dirty Pipe Copy Fail.
Dirty Frag, ja.
Haben den Namen für mich gut.
So, also, was trailert in Go?
Trivi, Agents View.
Trivi kennen wir, haben wir sogar auf der Arbeit im Einsatz.
Hatte auch Supply Chain Probleme vor einem halben Jahr oder so.
Ist das nicht gerade was doofes mit den Auer-Paketen, Manager?
Infizierte Pakete mit Nerva.
Ja, doch, da habe ich mich am Anfang des Streams schon drüber ausgelassen,
für eine halbe Stunde.
Wenn ihr in den letzten zwei Tagen eure Arch-User-Repo-Packages installiert habt,
dann könnte es sein, dass ihr betroffen seid von einem Supply Chain Angriff.
Ihr könnt das aber ausprobieren, ob ihr davon betroffen seid, wenn ihr das hier ausführt.
Ich würde euch natürlich nicht unbedingt empfehlen, random irgendwelche Sachen runterzuladen aus dem Internet
und dann auszuführen. Ihr könnt euch das Skript herunterladen und nach Bash pipen.
Bin ich betroffen? Ihr könnt euch angucken, so welche Hour Packages ihr installiert habt
und ob die betroffen waren.
Letztendlich wurde
mal wieder
ein manipuliertes NPM-Package
hochgeladen
und dann wurde eine Art User-Repo-
Build-Skript so manipuliert, dass sie
dieses NPM-Package installieren.
Das hatten wir schon.
Okay, also was trennt er denn sonst noch?
What's Mio?
Miau.
Bifrost.
AI.
JuiceFS.
Ein POSIX-Filesystem
built on top of Redis und S3.
Aha.
Redis wahrscheinlich, damit es schneller wird.
was nicht alles gibt mittlerweile.
AI, Rastic,
Rastic kennen wir schon,
Backup-Stells, Offsite-Backup,
AI,
SQL für Git-Repo-Sachen,
habe ich letztens ein Video drüber gesehen,
habe ich nicht so
ganz gecheckt.
Also kannst
da quasi deine
SQL, deine Tabellen irgendwie versionieren und forken und so.
Ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Traffic.
Trended.
Traffic ist nice.
Das einzige, was mir bei Traffic überhaupt nicht gefällt, ist die Config, weil man sie manuell von Hand anlegen muss.
Die ist echt hässlich.
Und kompliziert.
AI.
Master DNS VPN.
Ulama.
Adbird, Airclown, auch Offside-Backup.
Emporal, Terraform.
Wundert mich, dass OpenTofu nicht öfters trendet.
Kubernetes trendet, Terra, Crunt, Ethereum, Mediaserver, Citadel, Navitrom, your personal
streaming service.
Ah, für Linux-Distribution, ganz klar.
Ne, das meiste bei Go kennen wir schon
Bei Go sind es aber echt auch immer wieder die gleichen
Was trennt denn eigentlich bei ABAP
ABAP Git, okay
Hätte ja sein können
Irgendwas Spannendes bei ABAP trennt
Oder das allerwichtigste zum Schluss noch
Kobol
Was trennt denn bei Kobol
Und bei Fortran
Leute, was ist hier los?
Bei Fortran trendet
Guckt mal, guckt mal
Bei Fortran trendet eine Repo
Weekly mit 0 Sternen
Wie funktioniert das?
Wie kann man
Wie kann man im Weekly Sterne Rating
Trenden
Wenn man 0 Sterne die Woche hat
Also es scheint sehr beliebt zu sein
Fortran auf GitHub
E3SM Project
alles klar, wir sollen Maint
Maint sollen wir verwenden
Maint
ok, was auch immer
wir gucken uns jetzt diesen wunderschönen
Fortran Source Code mal kurz an
dass ihr mal seht, wie hässlich der Kram war
äh, wo geht man da hin hier? Components?
äh
Emulators? Keine Ahnung
Driver, Source,
das C++,
das ist gar nicht Fortran.
Wo findet man in einem ordentlichen Fortran-Projekt
denn
den Source-Code überhaupt?
Hier?
Ne.
Chat, wo würdet ihr
hier den Source-Code suchen?
Da ist die Moab!
Da ist die Moab
Aber hier
Guck mal, hier sind es 80% vortragen
Wo würdet ihr das denn hier suchen?
Components, oder?
Components klingt doch irgendwie sinnvoll
Components? Hallo
Oh, come on, GitHub
Components?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Homme, meinetwegen.
Source.
Ah, hier.
Excellent.
Main Vortrag 90.
Ah.
Ja.
Tolles Vortrag.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Witzigerweise lesbarer als C++.
naja okay okay okay vielleicht nicht vielleicht vielleicht auch nicht vielleicht auch nicht
einfach mal wie viele zeilen hat es einfach mal 4.221 zeilen
Nice
Ja
Fortran
Jetzt hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass so viele Fortran-Repos
Trenden aufgetappt
Das haben wir auf YouTube geguckt
Fortran
Doomlike FPS
In Kobol, das haben wir geguckt
Der hat das mit FFM-Pack gerendert
Das sind halt so uralte Dinger hier, ne?
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was ich hier anklicke.
Punkt F.
Das ist schon harte Koste.
Gut.
Aber haben wir uns die Trends angeguckt.
Diese Woche nicht wirklich was Spannendes dabei.
Schauen wir mal.
Was gibt es denn Spannendes auf YouTube?
Zollbeamte, juckt mich nicht.
Vago, Shelly.
Die Dinge finde ich tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Weil du dir bei Vago-Geräten
nicht die Gedanken machen musst,
dass der in der dose dann einfach irgendwann abfackelt
also diese videos immer die man hier empfohlen kriegt
Du bekommst sie nicht in die Dose rein.
Das ist natürlich auch kacke.
Was hältst du von einer neuen Xbox-Chefin?
Da habe ich mir noch kein Bild gemacht.
FF MPEG hackt.
Ach ja.
Ist das so?
Das müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Das interessiert mich.
Also ich habe ja auch schon in Softwareprojekten FFmpeg benutzt.
Wir skippen da mal kurz durch.
Das ist ja heute schon fast Standard, dass irgendwelche Lücken mit AI-Unterstützung gefunden werden.
Ja.
Also Leute, ich glaube so gut wie mindestens mal jede Seite, die Videos handelt,
Wahrscheinlich sogar jede Seite, die in irgendeiner Art und Weise Bilder handelt, verwendet heute FFmpeg.
Also es ist egal, ob es YouTube ist, ob es Twitch ist, ob es Pornhub ist, das wird alles FFmpeg sein.
Das stimmt.
Aber ist das wirklich, ist das in FFmpeg wirklich so kritisch?
Naja gut, potenziell, potenziell schon.
Du kannst ein manipuliertes Video unterschieben.
Und du hast dann, du hast dann, im schlimmsten Fall hast du halt Zugriff auf den Container oder die VM,
in dem der FFM-Pack-Prozess läuft.
Kannst da was machen.
Vielleicht, wenn es Internetzugriff hat, in irgendeiner Art und Weise noch eine Reverse-Shell starten.
Ja.
Ich finde übrigens, dass der FFmpeg Source Code, also für das, dass es so eine komplexe Software ist und auch so eine alte Software schon,
und dass das auch eine Software in C ist,
ist der FFmpeg
Source Code
erstaunlich gut lesbar.
Nicht alles,
ja, also bei manchen
Dingern habe ich mir auch schon an den Kopf gegriffen und gefragt, was wollt ihr
überhaupt von mir? Aber im Großen und
Ganzen ist das durchaus
okay. Und was auch
ganz gut ist, ist die
API, ja, also die
Funktion,
die man aufruft, beispielsweise
um Video zu parsen und sowas. Das ist ziemlich straight forward.
Also da ist schon viel Gehirnschmalz reingeflossen.
Ja.
Ah, Sellout, okay.
Ich spule mal kurz vor.
trost comes up at your company why don't you mention thrott locker thank you respond from
the video thrott locker let's get back to it when t1 vulnerabilities found at fm peggy
you'll notice that all of them have some kind of overflow stack overflow heap overflow integer
overflow a very common thing that occurs in c code base especially in c code bases that have
to parse user data if you consider that any one of the fields in the bmp so logisch could be
malicious for example files like the image height the image width the bits per pixel the x pixels
Das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen, etc.
Alle machen eine Art Mathematik, die in eine andere Location der Erinnerung, wo die aktuelle Pixel-Datei gestorben ist, bezieht.
Wenn any of these fields are malicious and not properly validated, it could lead to some kind of overflow or underflow in a calculation leading to access to memory outside of the bounds of this image data array.
Very simple use case.
Now, luckily, some of these bugs have only been around since 2023, some new file formats or new implementations of those file formats.
Aber eine in der Tat ist ein Stack-Based Buffer für Overflow, der seit 2003 vorhanden ist, mit der originalen SDT-Implantation.
Ich bin nicht sicher, was das ist. Es hat 23 Jahre lang auf dem Platz gesessen.
Und auch so, Plattformen wie Googles Big Sleep und ihre OSS-Fuzz-Repo,
Repos, die wir aktiv durch AI und Open-Source-Fuzzing suchen, durch diese Bemühungen, Bugs in FFmpeg zu finden,
konnten es noch nicht finden.
Der Bug, den der Blog-Autor bemerkt hat, was ein wirklich verrückter Bug ist, ist ein geschehener Frame-Marker für PC-Kontrolle.
Okay.
So rum hab ich da gar nicht dran gedacht.
Viele, viele, ähm...
Software-Packages verwenden ja vielleicht auch FFmpeg, um genau sowas zu machen.
Also VLC nicht. VLC hat ja ihr eigenes Media-Zeug, wobei ich glaube VLC auch um drei Ecken FFmpeg verwenden kann, wenn es verfügbar ist. Aber das stimmt schon. Dann hast du quasi, hast du mit FFplay oder so, hast du einen RTSP-Stream angemacht und auf einmal hast du einen Keylogger drauf.
real time data video data audio data the bug is actually crazy simple so when you receive a packet
from an RTSP server you get data that says what size the packet is and then you also use that to
track the current position in that packet you're processing they give it like a cursor when you're
doing a for loop over an array as the client side software the software and FFM peg is parsing this
OB you data the data inside of the element that you received every time it processes a byte it
calls a V grow packet so as it's reading data it's putting that data into packet data and growing it
also moving the packet position the cursor further along in the packet.
Ah, unless of course we put in an AV1 OBU temporal delimiter.
Again, I'm not an AV1 guy.
I don't know the spec very well.
But basically inside the spec, according to a document that I read,
it says in the spec that if you get a temporal delimiter,
you're supposed to simply drop the information.
Just get rid of it, move on, not a big deal.
And you see that here.
They move on by moving the packet position past,
by increasing the position by the OBU size,
removing the remaining amount of data by the OBU size
und incrementing the amount of OBUs they've processed.
But one thing you notice they didn't do
is they didn't call AVGrowPacket,
meaning the packet position could move out
past the bounds of packet data
and then allowing the user later
to write data to that position.
Because later on in the code,
after calling AVGrowPacket in a separate OBU...
Ja, und wenn du jetzt eine Software hast,
die das verwendet,
du öffnest den Stream, der AV1-encoded ist,
oder eine Datei,
schon kann irgendwas passieren.
Es sind natürlich immer zwei Paar Schuhe, ja?
So was zu finden und dann was zu finden, was auch noch irgendwie sinnvoll ausnutzbar ist.
Das sind ja immer zwei Paar Schuhe.
Zum Glück ist das schon wieder out.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Heap-Grooming, um ein Objekt, das zählt, oder ein Strukt, das zählt,
in den Buffer dieser Location zu stellen.
Wenn du Daten leaken willst, musst du Daten da reinlegen, die du leaken willst.
Vor zwei, drei Monaten sind alle nur rausgeflippt, wenn irgendwo 6-7 gefallen ist.
Wenn du einen Funktion-Pointer überwinden willst, musst du einen Funktion-Pointer da reinlegen.
Wenn du Code-Kontrolle und einfache Wege willst, musst du einen Funktion-Pointer
in den Heap-Buffer dieser Location reinlegen, damit du es überflöten kannst und diese Struktur überwinden kannst.
Und bada-bing, bada-boom, in der Struktur der AV-Buffer ist ein Data-Pointer,
Das ist quasi so eine Art manueller Destructor.
Du kannst quasi, du hast hier quasi eine Zeiger auf eine Funktion,
die dafür zuständig ist, diesen Buffer wieder aufzuräumen.
Code Control. Obviously a lot more has to happen to bypass mitigations like ASLR,
pointer authentication, a variety of other things. But this basic primitive is kind of how exploits
have worked for the last 30 years. And just in honor of POC or GTFO, the author here shows in a
stack trace that they set RIP to hex dead beef, showing they have arbitrary code control or at
least the primitive for code control inside of FFmpeg via this bug, which is really nuts. I'm not
sure how either fuzzing or AI have found this bug to begin with. Literally, this is like if you send
die Packet will get big enough and the packet will allow you to write outside of the bounds of another packet.
By using AI to identify invariants, which is actually exactly what the researcher calls out,
you look at this kind of packet and you should see pretty clearly it's the only packet that doesn't grow the packet by AV-Grow-Packet.
And then also through simple fuzzing, using ASAN and a variety of other fuzzers like OSS-Fuzz does.
Yeah.
If you're connecting to when you're using RTSP, sort of.
Okay, naja,
mal schauen. Ich hoffe, das Ganze ist schon gepatcht.
Guck mal hier. Wow, wow, wow.
So laut.
Wir haben Cloud 5 getestet.
Cloud 5
ist nicht...
Moment, es gibt Mythos, es gibt Fable.
Ist Cloud 5
das Gleiche?
Okay, whatever. Komm, wir gucken mal zur Abwechslung
ein Video, wo es um KI geht.
Ach, Cloud5 Fable, okay.
Jetzt hat Entropic Mythos veröffentlicht.
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, das KI-Modell, bei dem es vor zwei Monaten noch hieß,
das Modell sei viel zu gefährlich, um es zu veröffentlichen.
Weil man damit angeblich in die meisten Softwareprogramme einbrechen kann.
Ja, Fable ist wieder deaktiviert, ja, richtig.
Und deshalb hat sich Entropic einen Trick ausgedacht.
Das, was sie veröffentlicht haben, also was ich hier in diesem Video getestet habe,
nennen sie Fable.
Das ist laut Entropic aber Mythos. Aber halt Mythos, das sich weigert, Arbeit aus den Themenbereichen Cybersecurity, Biologie, Chemie und Wissensdestillation zu übernehmen.
Fable kann aber auch noch andere tolle Sachen, zum Beispiel besser coden als Opus. Das kann ich schon mal.
Und warum aus Biologie?
In diesem Video beantworten wir, ob Fable den Mythos-Hype rechtfertigen kann als unglaublich gefährliches, unfähiges Modell, wie ihr da drankommt, wie teuer das Ganze wird und ob das Modell endlich versteht, was auf meiner Kappe hier draufsteht. Bleibt dran.
Was bescheuert das jetzt schon wieder?
Bei den neuen Modellen von Anthropic sind Cyber-Sicherheit und Sicherheitslücken ein großes Thema.
Und damit kennt sich auch NordVPN, die sponsern dieses Video.
Tja, ich wurde nicht gesponsert von NordVPN.
Ich war mal kurz davor, eine NordVPN-Sponsoring zu machen.
Und dann hat NordVPN auf meinen Channel geguckt, das habe ich schon 500 Mal erzählt, ich weiß.
Dann hat NordVPN auf meinen Channel geguckt und festgestellt,
dass ich ein Video hab
Alter
ich halt zu Google
wenn DuckDuckGo das nicht findet
die Lügen der VPN Anbieter
und da sieht man
öfters ging es da auch um NordVPN
und das haben die gesehen und haben gesagt
dieses Video muss entfernt werden
hab ich gesagt
nö ich entferne das Video nicht
und dann haben die gesagt
ja dann wollen wir auch kein sponsoring machen und ja dann machen halt kein sponsoring vpn hat
über 8000 server in 126 ländern und in jedes davon könnt ihr euch rein tun und wusstet ihr
dass nord ich sollte ich sollte auch schon mal dass ich damals als ich auch call of duty sachen
gemacht habe da habe ich auch mal ein heftiges flame video bei activision gemacht das sollte
ich auch löschen damit ich irgendwo ein event eingeladen werde habe ich schon immer ich nicht
Ich bin ja auf den Scheiß glücklicherweise nicht angewiesen.
Ich verdiene ja meine Kohle anderweitig.
Und ich lösche aus Prinzip keine Videos,
nur weil sie irgendwie immer nicht gefallen.
Ich lösche höchstens Videos,
wenn ich mir selbst denke,
okay, heute
sehe ich das 180 Grad anders.
Aber das ist vielleicht ein, zweimal vorgekommen,
dass ich irgendwas gelöscht habe,
wo ich gedacht habe,
okay, das war vielleicht nicht so überlegt.
Also nur, wenn ich der Meinung bin.
Nicht, weil irgendjemand anderem das nicht gefällt.
Ja, Entropic hat es veröffentlicht.
Mythos bzw. Fable.
Mythos, übrigens griechisch.
Mythos für sagenhafte Geschichte.
Und Fable soll laut Entropic die lateinische Variante davon sein.
Streberkeno sagt, dass das eigentlich Fabula heißen müsste.
Aber okay, das weiß ich schon.
Auf jeden Fall sagt Entropic, dass Mythos und Fable wirklich erstmal grundsätzlich identisch sind.
Das kann man auch daran sehen, dass...
Tokens, Leute. Tokens gleich Profit. Haben wir das letzte Mal gelernt.
Entropic in seiner eigenen Benchmark-Tabelle Mythos und Fable in einer Spalte zusammenfasst.
Der Unterschied ist, dass bei Fable eine Erkennung vorgeschaltet ist, die merkt, ob ein verbotenes Thema angeschnitten wird.
Das läuft mit Constitutional Classifiers.
Wenn ihr das genauer wissen wollt, ich habe da ein Paper von Entropic verlinkt.
Dann aber auf jeden Fall, wenn der Classifier was erkennt, was böse ist, dann bricht er interessanterweise nicht die Arbeit ab, sondern gibt es einfach an das nächstbessere Modell, zur Zeit also Opus, weiter.
Das ist nicht dumm und auch transparent, denn Claude zeigt das an, wenn es die Antwort runterdelegiert.
Aber in der Praxis kann das natürlich auch nervig sein, vor allem wenn man gerne maximale Schlauheit hätte und das aber nie geht, weil es immer runtergestuft wird.
Wie oft dies runterstufen bei harmlosen Anfragen passiert, dazu sage ich später noch was beim Praxisteil.
Was ich auf jeden Fall nachvollziehbar finde, dass Cybersecurity-Anfragen erstmal nicht durchgehen, denn da scheint wirklich was dran zu sein, dass Mythos halt besser als andere Modelle Sicherheitslücken findet und das sind bekanntlich Einfallstore für Angreifer.
Das heißt, wenn man was Böses machen will, muss man nur herausfinden, was auf dem An...
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich, es dauert wahrscheinlich nicht lang.
Da gibt es ein ähnlich leistungsfähiges China-Chinesen-Model,
wo das eh wieder alles egal ist, was dann jeder benutzen kann.
Und man findet ja jetzt schon mit KI relativ viele Sachen,
wenn man nur lang genug laufen lässt.
...zugreifenden Computer oder Smartphone...
...haben wir eben bei FFmpeg gesehen.
...und für Software läuft und versucht dann mit Hilfe von Mythos
Schwachstellen bei eben dieser Software zu finden.
Wenn man die gefunden hat, dann darüber da einzubrechen.
Das geht mit anderen LLMs zwar auch, aber offenbar nicht ganz so gut.
Der andere gesperrte Themenbereich ist Biologie und Chemie.
Und da wird es schon etwas weniger nachvollziehbarer, für mich jedenfalls.
Angeblich will man verhindern, dass beispielsweise Biowaffen entwickelt werden.
Und ja, das klingt natürlich krass und so doll Science-Fiction-mäßig,
aber ob Leute, die sowas bauen wollen, wirklich so viel mit Claude Mythos anfangen können,
also im Vergleich zu einer normalen Suchmaschine, das ist offenbar auch in Fachkreisen umstritten.
Hier vermischen sich offenbar, wie so oft in der KI-Welt, wirkliches Risikobewusstsein und Marketing.
Also ein KI-Modell, was so mächtig ist, dass es bislang unbekannte Bio-Waffen entwickeln kann.
Boah, krass. Das kann ja wohl mindestens meine Steuererklärung dann auch erledigen, oder?
Also will ich das natürlich haben. Ist natürlich gute Werbung.
Als Optimist könnte ich jetzt sagen, ja, Entropic macht sich wir...
Vielleicht kann das auch Bann wieder von Rust zu SICK zurück-rewriten.
Ich habe Gedanken über die Sicherheit der Welt, aber sie nehmen halt den Marketing-Effekt auch gerne mit.
Als Pessimist würde ich denken, Entropic bereitet einfach nur den planten Börsengang mit möglichst viel Knalleffekt vor.
Achso, der dritte geschmerte Themenbereich ist Destillation, also nicht Schnaps brennen.
Wenn Entropic an die Börse geht, haben wir wieder ein paar Millionäre mehr.
Weil die haben bestimmt wieder viele Anteile.
Beantwortet Fable problemlos hier bei mir.
Das war ja bei SpaceX so, das war bei Facebook so.
Da hast du Instant Börsengang, also beim Börsengang hast du Instant große Anzahl Millionäre mehr.
Kann das Kobol wahrscheinlich?
Dann halt Wissensdestillation.
Also wenn man fürs Training eines Sprachmodells die Ausgaben eines anderen Sprachmodells, also hier Fable, verwendet.
Hier will Entropic also nicht die Welt beschützen, sondern nur sich selbst.
Sie wollen halt nicht, dass zum Beispiel chinesische Anbieter ihre LLMs mit Fable trainieren.
Beim eigenen Training war Entropic aber nicht so zimperlich.
Da wurden zum Beispiel Millionen Bücher eingekauft und fürs Einscannen dann zerstört, ohne vorher Lizenzen dafür zu holen.
Naja, okay.
Ein Riesenproblem ist, dass Fable es nicht anzeigt, wenn es meint zu erkennen, ob es zur Entwicklung eines neuen LLMs verwendet wird.
Also sowas wie der Aufbau von Pre-Training Pipelines und sowas.
Dann schaltet Fable einfach auf Dümmer, ohne dass man es bemerkt, ohne dass es angezeigt wird.
Und das steht tatsächlich schwarz auf weiß hier in der 319-seitigen System-Card.
Und viele Leute sagen, dass es wohl ziemlich häufig passieren könnte.
Und das Ganze ist halt intransparent. Das ist schwierig.
Vor allem, man gibt halt Geld aus für dieses teure Modell und womöglich läuft es dann oft runtergedummt, ohne dass man es weiß.
Einmal hier Kino aus der Zukunft.
Kurz vor Veröffentlichung dieses Videos hat Entropic angekündigt, in Zukunft nicht mehr ohne Hinweis runterzudummen.
Gut.
Stichwort teuer. Wie genau kommt man jetzt zu einem Fable und wie teuer ist das?
Ja, zur Zeit die günstigste Variante ist ein Pro-Abo bei Entropic.
Das kostet 20 US-Dollar, also hierzulande mitsteuern, ungefähr 21,50 Euro im Monat.
Und damit kann man Fable verwenden, aber jetzt kommt es nur noch bis zum 22. Juni.
Also wenn das Video hier rauskommt, noch 10 Tage.
Dann fällt das aus allen Entropic-Abos raus, auch den viel teureren.
Man kann dann nur noch pro Token mitzahlen und das ist immens teuer.
10 Dollar für eine Million Token-Input und 50 Dollar pro Million Token-Output.
Das ist exakt doppelt so viel wie bei Claude Opus.
Und ich kann euch sagen, als jemand, der Opus schon mal mit OpenClaw und tokenbasierter Abrechnung verwendet hat, schon da konnte man an einem Tag locker 500...
Sag doch, Tokens gleich Profit, hat uns doch der Nvidia-Chef das letzte Mal gesagt, da sieht man es wieder.
US-Dollar verblasen.
Das heißt, der nicht automatisch Profit für dich, oder das heißt ja nicht automatisch Profit für den Anwender.
Das heißt, auch wenn Fable angeblich tokensparsamer sein soll, wenn man da richtig was mit machen will, also Softwareprojekt oder so und auch richtig reinhaut, dann sind 1000 Dollar für einen arbeitssamen Tag auf jeden Fall möglich.
Und da kommen wir dann schnell zur Frage, ob sich das lohnt.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile schon wieder Unternehmen, die sagen, KI ist so teuer geworden, dass es sich wieder lohnt, richtige Menschen einzustellen, weil die billiger als KI sind.
Ja, auch mehr.
Auf jeden Fall sagt Entropic, dass es Fable so schnell wie möglich wieder in die Abos integrieren will, wenn es denn genug Rechenzentrumskapazität hat.
Ja und apropos Rechenzentrum, wenn ihr jetzt denkt, hä, ihr habt doch neulich im Computex Nvidia Video den KI-Rechenzentrumsbau-Wahn so kritisiert und jetzt testet ihr das nächste Hype-KI-Modell, was ziemlich sicher sehr ressourcenintensiv arbeitet.
Ja, das stimmt. Das kritisieren wir auch nach wie vor, aber wir wollen euch natürlich auch weiterhin ohne Hype-Brille über neue KI-Entwicklungen informieren.
Und deshalb ist das für uns logisch, dass wir natürlich weiterhin KI-Zeugs testen.
In Zukunft wollen wir aber auf jeden Fall mehr auf lokale LLMs eingehen.
So, aber das nur als Einschub zurück zu Fable, jetzt ans Eingemachte.
Was kann das Ding denn jetzt?
Beispiel 1, Kappe erkennen.
Ich sammle gerne Fehler von LLMs, weil ich so ganz gut nachvollziehen kann, ob Modelle besser werden.
Also ich gucke dann, ob neuere Modelle immer noch die Fehler machen.
Und ein interessanter Fehler war neulich die Erklärung einer Baseballkappe, die ich in Japan gekauft habe.
Und ich hatte die nur deshalb gekauft, weil das die einzige war, die mir gepasst hat.
Aber da ich kein Japanisch kann, wusste ich nicht, was da drauf steht.
Und das ist halt ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man mit irgendwas rumrennt, was man nicht versteht.
Das kann ja durchaus peinlich werden dann.
Deshalb muss ich mich schon darauf verlassen können, was mir das Sprachmodell sagt.
Und ich habe aber auch inzwischen echte Menschen, also japanisch kundige Menschen gefragt, die mir die Kappe erklärt haben.
Das C hier ist das Logo von dem Baseballteam Hiroshima Toyo Carps, also Carps mit C, daher auch das C.
Und das ist eingebettet in ein Wortspiel.
Da oben steht Jure und wenn man das zusammen mit dem C ausspricht, was...
Ich hätte nicht mal erkannt, dass es überhaupt ein C sein soll.
...in Japanisch wie Shi klingt, wird daraus halt Ureshi.
Und das heißt wohl beides zusammen, Uri und Shi, also Uri-Shi, glücklich.
Und um das noch zu unterstreichen, ist da so ein Lachmund drin in dem C.
Also ist eigentlich alles ganz süß.
Ja, aber guck mal, was Google Gemini 3 Flash Thinking draus macht.
Crossover Merchandising Artikel mit Bacabon no Papa?
Die Schriftzeichen bedeuten Pferd.
Und das wäre ja auch logisch, weil es gibt ja oft Kooperationen zwischen Baseballteams und der japanischen Pferderennvereinigung.
Was? War das?
Also, dass das Quatsch ist, konnte ich mir schon selbst herleiten, weil es bei Baccarbon no Papa ganz klar keine Figur gibt, die so einen Mund hat. Das sieht da total anders aus. ChatGPT dagegen meint, dass hier das Kanji-Zeichen für Reis zu sehen ist und dass das also schmeckt geil bedeutet. Und das alles immer in diesem altklugen Oberchecker-Ton, was halt wirklich nervt, wenn die Modelle halt klar halluzinieren und aber so tun, als wüssten sie alles.
Ja, Chat-GPT ist Meister im Dummschwätzen.
Ah, Classic.
Und Claude Fable, ja, das kriegt die Antwort auf Anhieb auch nicht komplett hin,
aber es halluziniert nicht und das ist ja erstmal das Wichtigste.
Und es erkennt auch das Ureshi-Wortspiel, aber eben nicht, dass das C zu den Hiroshima-Carbs gehört.
Es bietet aber an, im Netz zu gucken und das schafft es dann auch so erfolgreich,
dass es wirklich die konkrete Kappe im Carbs Fanshop findet und auch direkt weiß, in welchen
anderen Farben es die noch gibt. Das klingt jetzt profan, aber das hat bei meinen Tests kein anderes
aktuelles Sprachmodell hinbekommen. Beispiel Nummer 2, 3003 Logo manipulieren. So, aber jetzt zu den
Coding-Fähigkeiten. Ich habe Fable gesagt, und zwar über den Coding-Harness ClothCode. Es soll doch
bitte unser 3003 Logo als PNG nehmen und das Ding als Web-App möglichst beeindruckend interaktiv
verändern auf drei unterschiedliche weisen.
Mind-blowing-Arten
interaktiv verändert wird. Da kam dann nach ungefähr 15
Minuten herumgecodet das hier raus.
Und ja, das ist nicht schlecht, finde ich. Partikelsturm
hier finde ich ein bisschen langweilig, aber
diese ölartige, bunte
Verflüssigung ist nice.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Excellent Subscription.
Und auch dieses
3D-Hologramm. Der Fable
Vorgänger Opus macht daraus mit gleichem
Das hier, das ist schon wirklich weniger cool, finde ich.
Bei OpenAR Codex sieht das so aus, aber man kriegt auch aus komplett lokal laufenden Modellen was raus.
Das ist Qen 3.6 27B mit 8-Bit quantisiert, was auf meinem Framework Desktop lokal läuft.
Als Harness habe ich Hermes verwendet.
Ja, darüber mache ich auch noch ein Video.
Könnt ihr aber gerne in die Kommentare schreiben, wenn ihr das sehen wollt.
Dann bin ich mir noch ein bisschen sicherer, dass ihr das wirklich wollt.
Beispiel Nummer 3, 3003 Website bauen.
Beim Website bauen, ja, da fand ich Fable jetzt nicht so richtig beeindruckend.
Ich persönlich würde sowieso eher keine komplett KI-generierte Website veröffentlichen, weil schon genug Slop im Netz ist.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das ist also alles hier nur zum Testen.
Also so sieht das jedenfalls bei Fable aus.
Ich finde gelungen, wie das aus dem Logo den ungefähren Font abschätzt und diesen Stil mit chromatischen Aberrationen.
Aber vieles ist auch einfach Quatsch.
Die Videos kommen nicht jeden Donnerstag, sondern jeden Freitag.
Fable nutzt auch nicht das offizielle CT4004 Logo, sondern denkt sich selbst eins aus und die Namen von den Podcastern stimmen auch nicht.
Und vor allem sind die ganzen Inhalte hier nicht eingebunden, sondern es gibt zwar Playbuttons, aber die playen nicht, wenn man darauf klickt, sondern die führen dann einfach auf YouTube oder Podigy.
Die von Opus gebaute Website finde ich nicht unbedingt hässlicher, muss ich sagen.
Die Inhalte sind hier auch nicht eingebunden und auch die echten Thumbnails sind nicht zu sehen, aber sonst finde ich das okay.
Ich habe auch mal testweise mit dem neuen chinesischen Modell Minimax M3 mit dem gleichen Prompt eine Website gebaut.
Ja, es ist nicht so weit weg von den teuren Cloth-Modellen.
Beispiel 4, SVG-Animationen.
Ja, und dann habe ich noch den beliebten Test probiert, SVG-Code zu generieren.
Kennt ihr ja vielleicht, habe ich von Simon Willison geklaut.
Er lässt immer Pelikaner Rad fahren.
Ich habe das mal mit dem Octopus probiert und Fahrrad finde ich ist halt wirklich eine gute Idee,
weil da halt mechanische Dinge passieren und es da wirklich oft zu Fehlern kommt.
Zum Beispiel bei den kleineren Flash Gemini Modellen, die Google seit einiger Zeit immer als Default vorschlägt auf GeminiGoogle.com
und die sind wirklich viel schlechter als Gemini Pro 3.1.
Ich glaube wirklich, Google will Compute sparen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall sieht, finde ich, auch der Octopus in Fable ein bisschen besser aus als in...
Geht doch halbwegs klar.
...Opus.
Also ich habe auch noch andere Auffälligkeiten gefunden.
Also einmal zum Beispiel die Sprache von Fable.
Hier, das war die erste Frage, die ich Fable gestellt habe.
Was müsste passieren, dass ich die in KI-Rechenzentren investierten Summen amortisieren?
Und in der Antwort nutzt Fable immer noch diverse typische LLM-Stilblüten,
die ich als Redakteur immer anstreichen würde, wenn ich die im Text sehen würde.
Die Bullen sehen die Amortisation bereits laufen.
Also Bullen sind umgangssprachlich was anderes.
Ich würde vielleicht sagen bullische Anleger oder so.
Schlimmer ist aber noch, dass Geld am Ende von echten Endkunden stammt.
Was sind denn unechte Endkunden?
Und auch ein Teil des Werts liegt in Verteidigung bestehender Geschäfte.
Also wer schreiben kann, schreibt so nicht.
Ja, und ich wollte euch ja auch noch sagen, wie oft der Sicherheitsmechanismus anschlägt, der Fable immer auf Opus runterstuft.
Ja, oft. Also immer, wenn ich zum Beispiel sage, kannst du meinen Code auf Sicherheitslücken überprüfen, kickt das sofort rein.
Klar, okay, das war ja auch so angekündigt von Entropic.
Aber was ich schon krass finde, die ziemlich harmlose Fragen aus dem Bereich Biologie, Biochemie, die schlagen auch an.
Zum Beispiel, wie funktioniert der mRNA im Stoff?
Naja, er antwortet dann halt mit Opus und das ist qualitativ schon auch okay, aber ist trotzdem halt doof, wenn man viel Geld für Fable zahlt und dann nur Opus bekommt, obwohl man gar keine Biowaffen entwickeln will.
Also ich würde schon trotz meiner Kritik sagen, dass Stand heute Entropic Fable 5 das leistungsfähigste Allround-Modell ist, was es zurzeit auf dem Markt gibt.
Ja, aber das wissen wir ja, das kann sich sehr schnell immer wieder ändern.
Und es ist auf jeden Fall auch das teuerste, vor allem weil man es ja ab dem 22. Juni auch wirklich nur noch über bezahlte Token und nicht mehr über eine Abo-Flatrate bekommt.
Und auch wenn ich gesagt habe, es ist das Beste, ob es sich lohnt, so viel Geld dafür auszugeben und das Teil dann auch noch sehr häufig auf der schlechtere Modell-Opus runter zu schieben.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es ist eh egal, ob sich das lohnt oder nicht, weil es gibt es nicht mehr.
Schwierig.
Ja, wie seht ihr das?
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben und gerne unseren Podcast hören.
Ja, ja, das war vor der Abschaltung.
In der Folge 4004, da sprechen wir auch nochmal über Fable und Mythos.
Tschüss.
Hallo, schön, dass ihr da seid.
Ups, Wollschkamm.
Guck mal hier, jetzt hat Entropic...
Warum ihr keine Glasfaser braucht.
Warum brauchen wir keine Glasfaser?
Brauch Glasfaser.
Das klang doch eigentlich gar nicht.
Oh, da haben wir doch schon geguckt.
Oh, mir keine Glasfaser.
Ah, 19 Minuten, ein bisschen lang.
Aber ich brauche Glasfaser.
Sobald Glasfaser am Start ist,
will ich Glasfaser haben.
Leider bauen die bei mir irgendwie nicht aus.
Das ist Shelly geliefert, die Vago.
Also auf die Dinger bin ich wirklich gespannt.
Weil den Shelly-Dingern traue ich immer nicht so ganz, dass die mir nicht doch nochmal irgendwann abfackeln.
Hast du das Urteil vom Landgericht München mitbekommen, dass Google für Falschinformationen in ihrer KI-Übersicht haftbar ist?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
du meinst hier, dass wenn du Google Suche machst
und das was dann oben
eingeblendet wird
Wetter sagt
ja das kann schon sein
aber ich traue Vago da
besser zu, was zu bauen, was
nicht abfackelt nach ein paar Monaten
Jahren als Shelly
kann man gucken, das interessiert mich
Die Frage ist halt, ob es reinpasst.
Gibt es auch bei den Meta über Zigbee?
Und WAGO betritt den Smart Home Markt nicht einfach mit leeren Händen.
Sie haben einiges in petto, was es so noch nicht gab.
Und zwar sowohl auf der Software als auch auf der Hardware Seite.
Ich freue mich drauf.
Ihr hattet euch unter dem News Video gefreut.
Zumindest hat WAGO, was so Elektronik Sachen angeht, einen ganz guten Ruf.
Ja, für Verteilerkästen.
Da gibt es die WAGO Klemmen in allen möglichen Ausführungen.
Die bauen in der Regel Zeug, was taugt.
Wir haben uns zu früh gefreut.
Ich habe den Aktoren in den letzten Wochen auf den Zahn gefühlt und sage dir heute,
was es mit den Vago-Aktoren auf sich hat und ob du es wagen kannst zuzugreifen oder wann lieber nicht.
Vago startet mit insgesamt acht Geräten in den Markt, damit du möglichst viel in Zukunft direkt mit diesen...
Okay, lass mich mal raten, was für Geräte werden das sein?
Ganz normales Relay-Zeug zum Schalten, einen Dimmer,
so ein Rollo-Aktor
vielleicht.
Wo du so Plänten und so hoch und runter
machen kannst.
Ja. So die Standard-Dinger
halt. Mal gucken.
Die werden bei dir zu Hause
in die Dosen gebaut. Natürlich von
einem ausgebildeten
elektriker ausstattung für einen eigenen elektriker fachbetrieb gibt es wie immer
bei mir im shop und schon kannst du dein licht vom handy schalten oder dem deine rollläden
automatisch steuern den zustand einer steckdose zum beispiel der waschmaschine direkt überwachen
und so vieles mehr die grenze sind quasi unendlich und mit der vde zertifizierung gibt es endlich ein
sicheres smart home für uns alle außer dass viele auch schon ohne vde genutzt hat bei all dem lob
für die Geräte gibt es auch bittere Pillen
zu schlucken. Die vier Akteurtypen
gibt es jeweils in zwei Geschmacksrichtungen.
Entweder Funk per WiFi
oder Funk per Thread.
Und so kommen wir auf 8.
Ach, WiFi oder Thread. ZigBee gibt es nicht.
Finde ich doof.
Aber okay.
Die Dinger könnten
sehr schön das ZigBee Mesh
ausbauen.
Geräte. Und wenn du dich jetzt...
Ja, Meta... Moment, Moment, Moment.
ZigBee ist ja das Übertragungsding.
Es gibt ja auch Meta über ZigBee.
Meta ist quasi Layer 3.
Und Thread ist Layer 2, sozusagen.
Aber das ist nicht so.
Du fragst, ob ich mein Skript von einer AI habe schreiben lassen,
weil du hier ja nur 6 stehen siehst.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Die DIMM-Aktoren kommen später.
Einer mit WiFi, einer mit Thread.
Dann kommen wir auf 8.
Den DIMM-Aktor muss ich dann leider nachreichen.
Das ist schade, weil ich mich auf den fast am meisten gefreut hatte.
Gerade nachdem ich die Software auf der Light-In-Building in diesem Video gesehen hatte.
Aber schauen wir uns einfach an, was wir jetzt hier haben.
Und du abonnierst einfach so lange den Kanal.
Und dann verpasst du nicht, wenn ich was zum DIMM-Aktor mache.
Hier sehen wir einen der Aktoren.
Die sind von der Gehäuseform im Prinzip alle gleich.
Im Zweifel unterscheiden sie sich bei den Anschlüssen minimal.
Und wie wir das von WAGO-Klemmen kennen,
haben auch die Aktoren hier
so kleine Hebel,
mit denen ihr die Kabel, wenn sie
eingesteckt sind, fixieren könnt.
Sellout. Ich habe heute genug
selloutet. Falsche Kabel.
Also nehmt das nicht als Anschlussdiagramm.
Aber. Nachher. Beim nächsten
Banner wird geselloutet.
Ansonsten könnt ihr ja mal auf den Link
im Banner klicken. Und das ist ganz nett.
Und bei meinen Versuchen, das an verschiedenen
Stellen einbauen
zu lassen,
war das manchmal ein bisschen angenehmer.
Bei der Konkurrenz, die keine Klemmen hat.
Das sieht mehr so nach
Vera
Vera Dings hier
Set aus mit diesem, wie nennt man das?
Dieses Vera VDE Set, wo du
diese unterschiedlichen Klingen für den Traumdreher hast.
Dieses Werkzeug,
mein Alltagshelfer, das
VDE Big Pack von
Vera. Manchmal war es auch etwas schummeliger,
dann noch irgendwo rumzukommen und den noch festzuziehen.
Was wir aber auch sehen,
der Kollege hat schwere
Knochen. Die sind wirklich riesig.
Also hier ist zum Vergleich
mal ein Shelly 1.
Das ist schon richtig
fett.
Das ist natürlich schwierig da rein zu kriegen.
Guck mal wie fett die Dinger sind.
By the way, heute gibt es wieder
Chat, was gibt es heute bei mir zu futtern?
Es gibt wieder den Klassiker.
Einen der Klassiker.
Und es ist nicht Spaghetti Bolognese.
Es ist Nudel mit Lachs.
Das stimmt aber nicht ganz.
Es ist heute Lachs mit Reis.
Aber trotzdem der Klassiker.
Vierte Generation.
Da sehen wir schon, dass das einfach ein ganz anderes Größenverhältnis ist.
Aber warum braucht WAGO so viel mehr Platz für die gleichen Funktionen?
Schlimmer noch, für weniger Funktionen.
Da kommen wir gleich auch noch zu.
Die WAGO-Aktoren sind die ersten, die VDE-zertifiziert sind.
Damit ihr sicher sein könnt, dass das alles klappt.
Und damit ein Gerät wie dieses hier, ist das der?
Die 16 Ampere Variante.
Nee, keine Soße. Ich hau mir da immer ein bisschen Eiweiß drauf.
Das ist so Paprikamatsch.
Das stimmt, neues Produkt, doppelt so groß wie die Konkurrenz.
Aber WAGO hat wahrscheinlich auch mehr Zeug, was sie einbauen mussten, damit sie VDE-zertifiziert sind.
Ja, Patrick, das denke ich auch so.
Also ich würde den WAGO-Dingern deutlich mehr trauen.
... auch wirklich 16 Ampere aushält, fordert die VDE, dass der in Wirklichkeit mehr kann.
Der hier kann wohl 25 und das verbaute Relais kommt mit Anlaufströmen bis 120 Ampere klar.
Und damit musst du wirklich keine Angst haben, dass die Kiste irgendwelchen Aufgaben im normalen Haushalt nicht gewachsen ist.
Egal, ob du eine Infrarotheizung, Heizlüfter, Gartenpumpe oder eben die erwähnte Waschmaschine hier dran anschließt, sie werden ihn nicht überfordern.
Was euch dagegen überfordern könnte, ist den Kollegen in eine bestehende Unterputz- oder hier Hohlraumdose zu prügeln.
Also bei klassischen Dosen kannst du das einfach direkt abschminken.
Also zumindest, wenn noch irgendwie...
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt Kacke.
Dann sind sie ja doch keine richtige Alternative zu den Shellys.
Weil was bringt es dir, wenn du so ein dolles zertifiziertes Ding hast, was ich auch gerne hätte, aber wenn du das Ding so reinkriegst?
Oder eine Steckdose mit da rein soll.
In so eine 61er-Hohlraumdose habe ich den zusammen mit den neuen Gira-Steckdosen reinbekommen, aber es war auch ein bisschen Gewürge.
Also je nachdem, wie die angeschlossen sind und ich glaube nicht, dass ein Elektriker große Freude daran hätte, ein ganzes Haus zu installieren,
gerade wenn eine Waschmaschine vielleicht mit zweieinhalb Quadrat angeschlossen ist, also dem dickeren, starren Kabel, so wie dieses hier.
Bei 68er Dosen sollte es dann gehen und wenn du neu baust, dann würde ich dir diese Dosen mit dem hängenden Sack ans Herz legen.
Zumindest wenn du planst, Vago-Aktoren zu verbauen, dann ist es überhaupt kein Thema.
Dann kannst du die da hinten drin auch so halb versenken.
Also so Dosen habe ich definitiv nicht.
Und dann hast du hier vorne Platz ohne Ende.
Also dieser, weiß ich nicht, Kehlkopf-Sack oder wie heißt das bei den Pelika, ist doch egal.
Und das ist tatsächlich wahrscheinlich das größte Ausschlusskriterium, gerade in vielen Altbauten.
wirst du diese kleinen Klopper einfach nicht hinter einen Schalter gequetscht bekommen.
Natürlich ist die technische Überlegenheit super cool, hilft dir aber einfach kein bisschen, wenn sie nicht in die Wand passen.
Was du bekommst, wenn sie passen, zeige ich dir gleich.
Aber erstmal, schau dir mal an, was ich jetzt mit meinen Schaltern machen kann.
Hier aus diesen langweiligen Bauwippen kann ich jetzt professionelle Beschriftungen machen.
Denn ich habe jetzt ein Eufy E1, einen UV-Drucker für alle.
Eine Runde Sellout.
Überall draufdrucken und das in Millionen lebensechten Farben.
Und das geht auf den Tastung Geschmack vor.
Was? Ein UV-Drucker?
Also es gibt so viel geiles Zeug mittlerweile, was man irgendwie haben will,
aber nicht braucht, aber irgendwie haben will.
Da brauchst du, ich bräuchte ein eigenes Haus nur für Bastelkram.
Oder eben nicht.
Ein UV-Drucker druckt im Prinzip, wie du das kennst, nur härtet er die Farbe direkt aus
und kann dann weitere Schichten direkt übereinander drucken.
und so Reliefs und Texturen mit bis zu 5 mm Tiefe erzeugen.
Also könntest du auch Blindenstift auf deine Taste drucken.
Oder eine Ledertextur auf einen 3D-Druck.
Das ist schon richtig nice.
Oder auf billiges Plastik.
Und mit der neuen Flexible White Ink kannst du auch auf flexiblen Untergründen drucken
und damit kannst du eigentlich alles individualisieren,
weil der auf über 300 unterschiedlichen Materialien druckt.
Die Drucke sind wirklich erstaunlich robust
und auch als UV-Druck-Anfänger kann ich das alles kinderleicht bedienen.
Da die meisten Bilder aber keine tiefen Informationen haben,
kann die App einfach welche erzeugen.
Mit den modularen Aufsätzen erweitern sich die Möglichkeit,
dann auch noch auf runde Untergründe drucken zu können
oder bis zu 10 Meter lange Motive einfach durchzuziehen.
Und das alles in diesem kompakten Gehäuse.
Eufi, das ist Anker, ja. China-Chinesen-Kram.
Deko-Drucken, alles Mögliche individualisieren
und allein mit dieser Kiste euren eigenen Etsy-Shop an den Start bringen.
Und jetzt zum Prime Day gibt es den E1 mit bis zu 400 Euro Rabatt
und es gibt auch limitierte Flash-Sale-Geschenkkarten mit bis zu 1000 Euro Gesparnis und noch weitere Extras.
Mit meinem Code SPIELUNDZEUG sparst du zusätzlich.
Alle Informationen dazu findest du unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Okay, wie viel kostet denn sowas?
ganz ehrlich das geht ja noch das ist zwar schon ordentlich aber das geht ja noch
schreiben vielen dank an den youfie make eins für die unterstützung dieses videos und die
beschriftung einer baubeck bei der einrichtung gibt es bei wagen noch mal was besonderes sie
Sie haben den ganzen Prozess auch aus Sicht eines Elektrikers durchgespielt, der im Zweifel schon bei sich im Betrieb viel vorbereiten möchte,
bevor er auf die Baustelle fährt, um dann möglichst wenig vor Ort machen zu müssen.
In der WAGO-App lassen sich die Geräte eben scannen und schon mal einstellen.
Und dann wird eine gesamte Konfigurationsdatei für das Haus oder die Wohnung installiert.
Und dann kann entweder der Bewohner oder der Elektriker das in der WAGO Home-App einmal einspielen.
Und von dort kann man das Ganze...
Die haben sich halt was bei gedacht. Da merkst du halt auch, aus welchem Bereich die kommen.
Das Smart Home System der jeweiligen Plattform schieben, also am iPhone eben in Apple Home.
Und keine Sorge, du kannst sie auch einfach in der WAGO Home App direkt hinzufügen.
Nur für das ganze Haus oder eine ganze Wohnung gibt es eben diese Stützräder für deinen Elektriker.
Das Ganze funktioniert auch gut und solide und insgesamt auch von den Gesprächen, die ich mit WAGO auf der Light & Building und auch jetzt geführt habe, gehen sie voll rein in die Meta-Thematik.
Es funktioniert wirklich alles über Meta, also die Konfiguration der einzelnen Aktoren sogar auch.
Allerdings gibt es auf der Meta-Seite noch keine eigene Konfigurationsebene.
Aber die Kommunikation läuft zumindest darüber und das hat ein paar Folgen, über die wir auch kurz sprechen müssen.
Wenn du das machst, wie eben beschrieben, du richtest die Aktoren über die WAGO Home App ein und fügst sie dann darüber am iPhone zu Apple Home hinzu.
ist alles ganz einfach. Du benutzt sie wie du willst. Du schaltest dein Licht per App,
per Sprache oder eben am Schalter oder Taster. Aber wenn du zum Beispiel umstellen willst,
ob du einen Schalter oder einen Taster hast, dann musst du eben die Konfiguration in der
WAGO App vornehmen. Und da kannst du sagen, nein, das ist ein Switch. Und diese Konfigurationsänderung
wurde gerade per Meta auf diesen Aktor übertragen. Und der verhält sich dann in der Folge so,
wie du es ihm gesagt hast. Aber das hier ist ja auch ein Meta-Gerät. Du kannst ja auch sagen,
die ganze WAGO-Seite interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Ich nehme den aus der Packung, der hat ein
Meta-Code auf der Rückseite und ich lerne den einfach direkt in Home Assistant an und fertig.
Und das kannst du machen, aber dann fehlt der WAGO-App eben die Möglichkeit, mit dem
Akteur zu kommunizieren.
Und das kannst du auf zwei Arten lösen. Also
vor der Einrichtung in Home Assistant,
Ikea, Homey, was auch immer
du benutzt, konfigurierst du das
einmal mit der Vago-App und fügst sie
dann hinzu. Oder
du fügst es erst in Home
Assistant hinzu und dann benutzt du diese
Multi-Meta-Management-Funktion,
generierst einen weiteren Code und
fügst das Ganze dann in Apple Home
als sekundären
Meta-Controller hinzu.
Und dann hat Vago darüber
wieder einen Weg mit dem
Aktor zu kommunizieren.
Das soll in Zukunft auch dann direkt
in der Vago-App gehen, diesen Code
hinzuzufügen und zu konfigurieren.
Aktuell ist es nicht
möglich. Es ist auch nicht wirklich schlimm.
Man muss nur wissen, wie man sich behilft,
wenn man das nicht
in Apple Home oder in Google Home
am Android-Handy benutzt.
Das Blöde ist halt, ich finde das
eigentlich richtig nice,
aber ich kriege das bei mir in die Dose nicht rein.
Ich hoffe, die bauen demnächst noch mal ein bisschen was
kleineres, sofern es dann auch
VDE zertifiziert kriegen.
Noch weitere gute Nachrichten. Ich stelle mal kurz die
WAGO App auf Deutsch um, damit ihr seht, wie die
meisten von euch das sehen.
Da könnt ihr einmal sehen,
Schalter, Taste umstellen, das was ich eben gemacht
habe. Du kannst aber bei den
Geräten auch hier unten
die Verbindungsoptionen umstellen.
Also du kannst die
Schaltung und
den Ausgang entkoppeln.
Und was bedeutet das?
Wenn du hier auf ausschließlich Meta
umstellst. Also normalerweise,
wenn du so einen Aktor hinter
einen Lichtschalter baust oder vielleicht
realistischer diesen hier mit
den zwei Ausgängen, dann
kann der 2x6 Ampere
schalten. Das sollte jeder Wohnzimmerbeleuchtung
gewachsen sein. Was das Vago denn kosten soll?
Das ist wahrscheinlich
durchaus etwas teurer
als so ein Shelly.
Gucken wir mal.
Die zwei da.
55 Euro.
Kosten die.
Und eine ganze Ecke teurer als Shelly.
Kannst du eben
in der Regel entweder
per Smartphone oder womit auch immer.
Wie gesagt, ich finde den Preis durchaus
in Ordnung.
Aber
es bringt mir halt nichts, wenn es nicht passt.
Leuchtmittel steuern oder eben weiterhin am Schalter. Das kannst du hier auch, wie du siehst, aber wenn du das entkoppelst, dann kann der Schalter in deiner Wand ein Meta-Schalter sein und dein Decken- oder hier Wandlicht eine Meta-Leuchte, die nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Du kannst dem Licht Dauerstrom geben, weil da vielleicht eine smarte Birne dranhängt und dann mit dem Schalter einen Steuerbefehl an das Leuchtmittel schicken, wie es sich einstellen soll.
Du kannst es aber auch für was völlig anderes benutzen.
Du kannst ja mit dem ehemaligen Lichtschalter...
Ja, das ist so. Die coolen Leute sagen nicht Lampe, die sagen Leuchtmittel.
... den Rollladen fahren lassen und das Licht steuerst du dafür über die Taste am Rollladen oder per Sprache.
Oder du kannst auf den Taster oder hier auf den Schalter eine Szene legen, die bestimmte Einstellungen an dem...
Ah gut, das müssen wir jetzt nicht gucken.
Energiemessung, okay, das ist tatsächlich auch ganz interessant.
...um mir einfach das bessere Smart Home für die Zukunft zu bauen.
Vielleicht ist dir aber aufgefallen, dass wir über eine zentrale Funktion bisher noch nicht gesprochen haben.
Die Energiemessung. Das liegt daran, dass die keine Energiemessung haben.
Ach, das ist ja doof.
Das ist der zweite Schlag in die Magengrube.
Also je nachdem, wann du dieses Video schaust.
Denn man sagte mir, die Aktoren können das alle.
Das wäre nur noch ein Software-Update von uns weg.
Und das kommt irgendwann.
Das muss dann Meta-Zertifizierung sein.
Das kann dauern.
Als ich das gehört habe, ist mir tatsächlich ein riesiger Stein
in der Größe eines WAGO-Aktors vom Herzen gefallen.
Denn bei all den technischen Absicherungen und VDE-Zertifizierung
ist für mich einfach ein wichtiger Teil,
dass gerade die 16 Ampere Version, die ich hier irgendwo hingepfeffert habe,
Moments later.
Jetzt habe ich es wieder gefunden, aber vergessen, wie ich den Satz angefangen habe.
Das finde ich auch nicht mehr.
Für mich ist ein wichtiger Teil, damit Energie messen zu können.
Damit sich jeder so ein Teil vor seine Waschmaschine und eins vor den Trockner schrauben kann,
also schrauben lassen kann, beziehungsweise man schraubt ja nicht mal,
also klemmen lassen kann und dann sowas wie Wash Starter zu benutzen,
um bei dummen Waschmaschinen die Stromverbrauchsmuster der Waschprogramme anlernen zu können,
um dann zu sehen, wie lange läuft die noch, in welchem Waschprogramm.
Und das alles aus dem Stromverbrauch.
Oder bei einem Handtuchheizkörper, der per Strom läuft, auswerten zu können, wie viel er verbraucht.
Hätte mir hier auch sehr geholfen.
Aber das soll ja zum Glück kommen.
Aber wie immer der Hinweis, wartet mit dem Kauf, wenn ihr das für diese Stromverbrauchsfunktionen kauft,
bis es wirklich da ist.
Es soll ja in der Vergangenheit den einen oder anderen Hersteller gegeben haben,
die versprochene Funktionen dann nie geliefert haben.
Und apropos Kauf...
Oder lokale APIs abgeschaltet haben, gab es ja auch ein paar.
Ich erinnere mich da an einen größeren Aufschrei bei, ich glaube, TP-Link war das.
Die Tuja-Geschichten gingen ja auch mal rein lokal.
Ich schreibe das mal vor.
Die gehen jetzt nach und nach in den Vertrieb,
wahrscheinlich zum großen Teil erstmal in den Großhandel an die Elektriker.
Aber der soll auch für Endkunden verfügbar sein.
Für 60 Euro das Stück.
Schaut gerne unten in die Videobeschreibung, da verlinke ich die ganz uneigennützig.
Das liegt natürlich preislich auch saftig über der Konkurrenz, genau wie bei der Größe.
Aber für das gute Gefühl, dass die mit allem in deinem Haushalt klarkommen,
dass sie VDE-zertifiziert sind, was vielen Elektrikern vielleicht auch gar nicht klar ist,
dass das bei allen anderen smarten Relais bisher nicht so gegeben ist
und sie die vielleicht gar nicht so richtig verbauen könnten.
Die können jetzt bei Vago vielleicht das Problem haben,
dass sie sie auch nicht verbauen können,
weil sie einfach physikalisch nicht passen.
Außer es sind blinde Dosen, wo jetzt nichts vorsitzt.
Oder, weiß ich nicht, in so einer Doppeldose.
Da habt ihr dann im Zweifelsfall auch noch ein bisschen Platz.
Oder ihr nehmt halt einen Meißel in die Hand.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall sehr angetan.
Die Vago-Aktoren sind schnell und zuverlässig.
Sie sollen sicher sein und kommen hoffentlich dann wirklich mit jedem Haushaltsgerät zuverlässig klar.
Gerade die Threat-Versionen schließen eine Lücke für viele Smart-Home-Besitzer.
Leider muss diese Lücke halt ziemlich groß sein, damit der da überhaupt reinpasst.
Aber sobald dann das Energiemessungs-Update für die Aktoren da ist, dann wird das schon richtig rund.
Funktionen wie das Entkoppeln sind super.
Beim DIMM-Aktor konnte ich auf der Light-End-Building schon sehen, dass man die DIMM-Kurven irgendwie fein justieren kann.
Darum freue ich mich auf den auch besonders.
Die Apps und Benutzeroberflächen sehen gut aus, funktionieren inzwischen auch zuverlässig für mich.
Es gab mit früheren Versionen ein paar Probleme mit meinem wilden Setup hier.
Die wurden aber schnell behoben und man ist bei WAGO wirklich hinterher,
einfach ein grundsolides Produkt zu bauen, soweit der Metastandard das zulässt.
Ich meine, bei der eigenen Klientel müssen sie das auch und man sieht es wirklich.
Also auch die App macht einen sehr guten Eindruck,
Aber es hilft halt alles nur, wenn es wirklich in deine Wand passt.
Unterputz tut sich gerade was.
Auch Philips Hue hat ja offenbar ein neues Wandschalter-Modul.
Völlig anderes Konzept.
Das müssen wir uns auch...
Ja.
Leider bringt es mir nichts.
Das Finanzfluss verklagt Meta.
Starlos.
Das Video habe ich schon geguckt.
Hier diesen Konferenztalk.
Den fand ich nicht gut.
Das fällt mir nur gerade ein, weil es hier eingezeigt wird.
das hat sehr vielversprechend angefangen und dann bestand die hälfte des videos
aus irgendwelchen wichtig zu leuten im publikum die sagen ja aber da könnte man
noch da und irgendwelche nachfragen fand ich nicht gut hätte viertelstunde sein
können vom inhalt her
Ist das die Xbox CEO?
CEO-In?
Nen?
Okay, ich glaube, ich habe die noch nie gesehen.
Definitiv kein AI-Bild.
Warum hier keine Glasfaser?
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich, warum wir das nicht brauchen.
Jetzt gucken wir mal.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Erstmal das hier zumachen.
Das hier wollen wir jetzt nicht gucken.
So funktioniert Apple Pay wirklich.
Okay, Chat, ich muss mal kurz
mein Handy holen.
Damit ich gucken kann,
was die Mikrowelle so macht.
Falls es Essen gibt.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, da bin ich.
Sekunde.
Home Assistant starten.
Home Assistant.
Und jetzt in die Küche.
Feststellen die Mikrowelle das noch nicht an.
Okay, excellent.
Neue Vectoring-Geschichten für Kupfer.
Zwei Adermit, zwei Gigabit.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das sinnvoll funktioniert.
Also selbst wenn es theoretisch funktionieren würde,
dann macht es keinen Sinn wahrscheinlich,
weil es irgendwie maximal über, keine Ahnung, fünf Meter geht oder so.
Immer nur Mikrowelle.
Ja, das liegt daran, weil das Essen ja schon fertig ist von gestern.
Äh, von.
Vorgestern?
Ne, gestern.
Vorgestern.
Listening, Leute.
Listening.
Das ist ein schönes E-Mail für...
Also, da gucken wir uns nochmal an, warum wir angeblich kein Glasfaser brauchen.
Die Nase voll.
Dauern stehen dubiose Direktvermarkter bei Menschen vor der Tür,
behaupten, dass demnächst die DSL-Verbindung gekappt wird,
um ihnen dann völlig überzogene Glasfaserverträge anzudrehen.
Die waren auch schon mal mir vor der Tür,
dass angeblich demnächst hier Glasfaser gebaut wird.
Hab ich gefragt, ob ich da mal im Internet nachgucken kann.
Tja, und dann waren sie wieder weg.
Aber das ist nicht mal geplant bei mir, hab ich dann rausgekriegt.
Und gleichzeitig erzählen irgendwelche selbsternannten Internet-Experten,
dass der Glasfaserausbau ja kompletter Schwachsinn sei.
Gibt es das wirklich? Das sind aber geile Experten.
Die aktuellen Geschwindigkeiten über DSL- und Coax-Kabel völlig reichen.
Was aus diesem Quatsch entsteht, ist riesige Verunsicherung bei denen,
die technisch weniger versiert sind und am Ende nicht wissen,
ob sie beim Thema Glasfaser einfach nur abgezockt werden und das Ganze völlig unnötig ist.
Mein Opa hätte sich im Leben kein Glasfaser ins Haus gelegt.
Der hat sich ja damals sogar dagegen gesträubt, Kabelanschluss ins Haus zu legen.
Das mussten wir dann erst machen, als wir hier umgezogen sind.
Oder hier eingezogen sind.
Oder ob sie etwas Wichtiges verpassen und jetzt tatsächlich handeln müssen.
Damit ich nicht in absehbarer Zeit Blutdruckmedikamente brauche.
Sobald ich die Möglichkeit habe, Glasfaser hier mir legen zu lassen, mache ich das instant.
... verarschen lassen müsst, erklären wir in diesem Video einmal genau, wie die alten Infrastrukturen entstanden sind
und weshalb der Glasfaserausbau technisch wie wirtschaftlich gesehen sinnvoll ist,
aber trotzdem keine Panik haben braucht, dass euch morgen die Verbindung gekappt wird.
Werfen wir erstmal einen Blick auf unsere alten Festnetze, wie diese entstanden sind und was sie heute leisten.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran? Bei Kabel, also Internet über Kabel, das ist ja shared. Also sprich, alle Leute an so einem, wie heißt das, Verteilerpunkt vom Anbieter, die sharen sich ja die gleiche Bandbreite.
da gab es früher richtige probleme dass das quasi maßlos so überverkauft wurde
und die leute dann abends richtige probleme mit dem internet mit dem
internetanschluss hatten erinnert sich da noch einer dran das schon ein
bisschen her mittlerweile ist es besser das war richtig kacke da hat da hat bei
mir zur damaligen zeit hat bei mir kabel internet aus ein schlechtes seinen
schlechten ruf aufgebaut mittlerweile sind die probleme gar nicht mehr glaube
zumindest nicht mal so nicht mal so groß da das war richtig ätzend so wichtig um zu verstehen was
die glasfaser am ende so besonders macht unser telefon jetzt ist die älteste noch betriebene
elektronische telekommunikationsinfrastruktur und heute das festnetz über das in deutschland die
meisten von euch im internet gehen aktuell sind so um die 25 millionen festnetzanschlüsse mit dsl
geschaltet diese infrastruktur war in den jahren vor dem internetboom relativ simpel aufgebaut man
Man hatte große Verteilerzentren, aus denen Bündelkabel abgingen, also große Kabel mit vielen Aderpaaren.
Und die führten dann in die kleinen grauen Kästen auf den Straßen.
Dort wurde das Bündelkabel mit seinen Adern dann auf Klemmstellen aufgelegt und auf die weiteren Kabel in die Häuser verteilt.
Das war im Regelfall komplett passive Technik.
Es gab natürlich auch Verstärker, aber meistens passiv.
Denn so ein analoges Telefonsignal konnte man durchaus über einige Kilometer übertragen.
Mit der ersten digitalen Telefontechnik ISDN, Integrated Services...
warte mal
digital
network ich habe keine ahnung
der ist aus sellout time heute link in der kanal beschreibung oder
jetzt ausrufezeichen sie geld ausrufezeichen ukraine kriegt der
günstige festplatten und günstige nasdaq über meinen alternate link und die preise
Geld nur über meine Autoladling.
Woanders ist es teurer.
Digital Network, Rest in Peace 2018.
Da war das ähnlich.
Die hatte nämlich auch nicht sonderlich viel mehr Bandbreite belegt,
so um die 150 Kilohertz.
Ja, und dann, dann kam der Internetboom
und DSL, also die Digital Subscriber Line,
die aus der Telefonleitung etwas gemacht hat,
für das sie eigentlich nie gedacht gewesen ist,
nämlich einen breitbandigen Datenkanal.
Mit den ersten DSL-Varianten,
Also A-DSL und S-DSL funktionierte die alte Verteilerstruktur noch so.
Wie schnell war das erste DSL nochmal?
768 Kilo...
Bit, oder?
Ja, 768, ja.
768, genau.
und 128 ab.
Da habe ich ja das Video drüber gemacht,
wie ich mich damals so gefreut habe,
als ich von der Schule gekommen bin,
dass es endlich geht.
Damals hatte man,
das muss ich jetzt sagen,
das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen,
damals hat man das DSL-Modem
direkt an seinen Computer angeschlossen
mit einer Netzwerkkarte
und da hatte man damals eine olle Windows-Kiste
mit Public-IP im Internet.
Das ist eigentlich so lächerlich, ne?
Wenn du das aus heutiger Sicht überlegst.
Aber das war damals so.
Windows-Kiste mit Public-IP im Internet.
Damals hat man sich dann Zone-Alarm und so Zeug installiert.
Als Firewall.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Zone-Alarm?
Ja.
So sah das aus.
T1.
Das, was damals so unter Standleitung lief.
So eine Arme.
Weil man mit niedrigeren Datenraten
noch immer einige Kilometer überbrücken konnte.
bei DSL 1000 und DSL 3000 zum Beispiel, also 1 bzw. 3 Megabit pro Sekunde.
Außerdem ist DSL von vornherein adaptiv gewesen, es passt sich also in gewissen Rahmen an die...
Igel-PC-Basis, die Dinger kenne ich auch noch, das war ein Pentium 2, ähm, 233 oder sowas drin, ne?
Das war ein Mini-PC, der nicht wirklich Mini war.
Avira und Sonalarm, ja, war damals Pflicht, war die erste Installation, die man gemacht hat.
Das Ding ist halt, wenn du damals einen Windows XP Rechner ungesichert ans Internet gehängt hast,
da hattest du innerhalb von 5 Minuten diesen, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie dieses Ding hieß.
Es gab damals so einen Virus, der sich über Port 445, glaube ich, verbreitet hat.
Über irgendwelche Windows Protokolle.
Und da hat sich der Rechner immer runtergefahren und sowas.
Das ist das Insiste. Wirklich, das hat ein paar Minuten gedauert.
War dann sofort verseucht.
Leitungslänge und die Qualität an.
Aus den Kilometern Leitungslänge wurden dann aber schnell wenige hundert Meter,
weil der Internetboom ja doch innerhalb weniger Jahre dazu geführt hat,
dass wir alle mehr Datenrate wollten.
Das geht aber über die klassische Kupfer-Doppelader nicht einfach so,
weil man dafür ja mehr Bandbreite im Kabel belegen muss.
Die Filozentriftenzen aber stärken.
Jetzt weiß ich, wie hieß das Ding.
Plaster
hat sofort alles infiziert innerhalb von
ein paar Minuten, wenn du das ohne
Firewall ans Internet gehängt hast.
An Windows-Kiste damals.
... als die Tieferen gedämpft werden. Das Signal wird also
schwächer und geht irgendwann ganz verloren.
Dadurch reduziert sich die Leitungslänge,
über die man wirklich schnell Daten übertragen kann.
Bei VDSL 1 mit
25 oder 50 Megabit...
Also VDSL 1, was war denn das?
500 Meter oder sowas?
Das war doch gar nicht mal so viel.
waren es noch so 800 bis 1000 Meter.
Bei VDSL 2 mit Vectoring,
das belegt so 35 Megahertz
im Telefonkabel, sind es
nur noch 200 bis 400 Meter, über
die das wirklich optimal klappt.
Das hat man also gemacht. Man hat dort,
wo früher die passiven Kästen standen,
Strom und Glasfaser hingelegt, größere
Kästen aufgebaut und die DSL-Technik
Ja, ja, Windows XP Service Pack, ich glaube,
2 war das.
Die haben ja Windows XP mit Service Pack 1
oder Service Pack 2, ich weiß auch nicht mehr, welches das war,
haben die ja komplett
grundlegend umgebaut.
Was übrigens auch der Grund war,
dass Windows Vista
so spät kam.
Windows XP SP2
war ja mehr oder weniger ein neues Windows Release.
Und man vermutet ja,
dass Vista
in der Form nur rausgebracht wurde,
damit man seine Support-Verträge
mit den Enterprise-Kunden einhält,
weil in den Support-Verträgen stand sinngemäß
sowas drin, wie alle fünf Jahre gibt es ein neues Windows.
Herangebracht,
weil es schlicht nicht anders geht.
Da ist also in jedem Kasten ein Gerät
drin, was einige Dutzend Anschlüsse versorgt
und ihr kriegt dadurch irgendwas
zwischen 75 und 300 Megabit
pro Sekunde im Downstream und bis zu
40 Megabit pro Sekunde im Upstream.
Reicht, aber ist heute halt auch noch mehr die Welt.
Auch wieder in Abhängigkeit
der Leitungslänge und der Qualität.
Man kann versuchen, noch mehr aus der
Telefonleitung herauszupressen. Dafür gibt es
dann G-Fast, wo sogar 1 Gigabit
pro Sekunde in beide Richtungen möglich ist.
Ja, aber was geht das? 10 Meter?
Aber das geht eben nur über
ca. 100 Meter Leitungslänge, weil
G-Fast 106 bzw.
212 Megahertz belegt, was
noch stärker gedämpft wird. Dafür muss
ich dann halt als Anbieter in den Keller von
Mehrfamilienhäusern und habe mehr...
Wenn ich das machen muss, kann ich auch gleich Glasfaser
legen. Dezentrale, aktive
Technik an der Backe, die Stromkosten
und Wartungsaufwand verursacht. Das wird
tatsächlich teilweise genutzt von Anbietern,
Aber bei Einfamilienhausvierteln lohnt sich das zum Beispiel schon gar nicht mehr,
weil ich pro Verteilerpunkt nur 8 bis 10 Häuser abdecken könnte
und dafür noch mehr Kästen oder Unterflughäuser bauen müsste
und, oh Wunder, Glasfaser in die Straße legen müsste.
Das Ende ist bei der Telefonleitung also erreicht, rein wirtschaftlich betrachtet.
Jetzt mögen manche von euch sagen, ja und, das funktioniert doch
und die meisten von uns kommen mit 100 bis 300 Megabit pro Sekunde völlig auf.
Das wird ja auch noch mehr in Zukunft.
Also man muss ja auch ein bisschen nach vorne gucken. Man braucht ja auch eine Technik, die zukunftsfähig ist. Wenn man immer so lange alles benutzt, wie reicht doch so, reicht noch gerade so, reicht immer noch gerade so und irgendwann hast du dann 20 Jahre lang, wie wir es gemacht haben, ja, nichts gemacht und stehst dann auf einmal doof da.
Wozu also Glasfaser?
Klar, das ist auch nicht falsch, verkennt aber die technische Realität.
Nämlich, dass der Bandbreitenbedarf über kurz oder lang wahrscheinlich weiter steigt.
Und viel wichtiger, dass VDSL schlicht ein unsicherer Kompromiss und keine Zugangsgarantie ist.
VDSL lässt sich aufgrund der ungeschirmten Telefonleitung nämlich sehr leicht stören.
Insbesondere, wenn die parallel zur Stromleitung laufen.
Schlecht gefitterte Netzteile, teilweise defekte Geräte, Powerline-Adapter, Kurzwellenfunkgeräte und so weiter und so fort.
All das kann VDSL von jetzt auf gleich instabil machen.
Und treffen kann das wirklich jeden, der VDSL nutzt.
Wer so eine Störung schon mal hatte und keinen engagierten Techniker der Ahnung hat und wirklich nach dem Problem sucht,
der wird wissen, wie frustrierend das ist.
Denn die Verbindung ist dann alles andere als stabil.
Wieso Glasfaser dieses Problem nicht hat, darüber sprechen wir gleich.
Erstmal kommen wir zum zweitgrößten Festnetz, dem Koaxialkabelnetz alias Kabelnetz oder Fernsehnetz.
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von Incogni.
So praktisch.
Yep, Incogni.
Das nutzen heute so ungefähr 9 Millionen Haushalte, um ins Internet zu gehen.
Das Koaxnetz entstand größtenteils in den 1980er Jahren als Rundfunknetz, also erstmal für diese Bilder da.
Für Radio und Fernsehen.
Zum Einsatz kam und kommt auch heute noch Koaxialkabel, wie der Name schon sagt.
Die Kabel bestehen aus einem Innenleiter, also einem Draht in der Mitte, einem Dielektrikum, also einem nicht leitfähigen Material, einer Schirmung und einem Mantel.
Durch den Aufbau, insbesondere durch die Schirmung, ist das Kabel wesentlich besser für höhere Frequenzen geeignet als die Telefonleitung.
Wir waren ja gerade schon bei den 35 MHz von VDSL.
Das Coax-Netz konnte schon in seiner ersten Ausbaustufe 300 MHz und später 450 MHz übertragen.
Selbst bei diesen vergleichsweise hohen Frequenzen ist die Dämpfung in dem Quarkskabel noch im Rahmen, sodass man gute Reichweiten über das Kabel erzielen kann.
Später zum Internetboom hat man das Netz dann umgebaut, damit es überhaupt erstmal rückkanalfähig wird.
Also die Verstärker einen bestimmten Frequenzbereich, 5 bis 65 MHz, vom Kunden zur Kopfstelle zurück verstärken.
Denn ohne Upstream gibt es ja keine Internetverbindung.
Außerdem hat man das Netz im Laufe der 2000er von 450 MHz auf erst 600 und später 860 MHz erweitert, also an vielen Stellen neuere, breitere Verstärker installiert, um mehr Platz für Programme und Datenverbindungen zu haben.
Im Kabelnetz nutzt man die Data-over-Cable-Service-Interface-Specification, kurz DOCSIS, um Internetverbindungen herzustellen. Das ist also das Pendant zur DSL, funktioniert aber grundlegend anders, weil das Kabelnetz keine individuellen Kabel aus der Kopfstelle bis zum Kunden hat und sich alle untereinander sehen, also hochfrequenztechnisch und somit auch stören können, anders als im Telefonnetz.
Deshalb wird bei DOCSIS der Kanal auf alle aufgeteilt und im Upstream ein Zeitschlussprotokoll genutzt, das regelt, welcher Router man senden muss.
Wie gesagt, das ist halt shared.
Durch die steigenden Datenraten und Nutzerzahlen während des Internetbooms kam es dann aber auch im Kabelnetz zu Problemen.
Innerhalb einer Domain, also zum Beispiel innerhalb einer Stadt oder einem Stadtteil, ist die Bandbreite ja schlicht begrenzt.
Wie gerade schon gesagt, alle sehen sich untereinander und man hat nur 600 bzw. 860 MHz frei.
Das waren die Probleme, die ich vorhin meinte.
Radio, Fernsehen und Internet nutzen muss.
Buchen zu viele Kunden einen Internetzugang, sinken zu spitzen Nutzungszeiten die Downlink- und Uplinkdaten und die Latenz geht hoch.
Die von euch, die in den frühen 2000ern und 2010ern bei Juridik Media, KB Baden-Württemberg oder KB Deutschland waren, werden sich eventuell noch an den Ärger durch Überbuchungen erinnern.
Gerade abends hat das Internet dann wirklich keinen Spaß mehr gemacht.
Wie haben die Anbieter das Problem gelöst?
Sie haben die eins großen Ortsnetze aufgetrennt, sodass ein Strang weniger Kunden versorgt hat und sind, wie bei VDSL, näher an den Kunden ran.
Dafür nutzt man natürlich auch die Glasfaser.
Es gibt da unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten, die wir jetzt nicht alle im Detail durchgehen werden.
Das Endergebnis ist jedoch ähnlich wie bei der Telefonleitung.
Man hat immer mehr dezentrale, aktive Technik auf der Straße, die zwischen Medien wandelt, also in diesem Fall zwischen Glas- und Quarkskabel.
und die Energie verbraucht und um die sich die Anbieter kümmern müssen.
Natürlich ist die Lage im Kabelnetz nicht ganz so kritisch wie im Telefonnetz,
weil die Technik etwas weniger störanfällig ist und vergleichsweise viel Bandbreite bietet.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja an fast allen Kabelanschlüssen Gigabit-Tarife.
Allerdings ist auch hier das Ende absehbar, bis zu dem sich die Fahnenstange sinnvoll verlängern lässt.
Denn das Kabel ist trotz seiner Bandbreite schon sehr gut ausgelastet,
ausgelastet, weil ja nicht nur Internet
darüber läuft, sondern heute auch ein
ganzer Batzen an Fernsehkanälen für free
und pay-to-view. Ey, ohne Scheiß, ne?
Ich hab letztens mal wieder Sendesuchlauf machen müssen,
weil die die Sender umgestellt haben bei Vodafone.
Wie viele unsinnige
Scheißsender man bekommt.
Alter!
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Ich muss, ich muss jedes Mal
99% der Sender einfach rausschmeißen.
Ich hab 11 Stück.
Die werden geguckt, der Rest ist einfach nur useless.
Keine Ahnung, warum es da so viele Schwachsinn, warum das überhaupt ein Ding ist.
stark gedämpft, dass man am Ende wieder im Mehrfamilienhauskeller oder eben draußen auf
der Straße kurz vorm Kunden ist.
Das frage ich mich auch, wie die alle Geld verdienen.
Damit das irgendwie noch sinnvoll klappt.
Und dann stellt sich wie bei VDSL und G-Fast die Frage, warum nicht einfach Glasfaser bis
zum Kunden ausbauen, damit das Thema ein für alle Mal gegessen ist.
Denn die Glasfaser ist mittlerweile günstiger als Kupferkabel und mit ihr hat man die ganzen
Probleme, die wir zuvor erwähnt haben, einfach nicht.
Die Glasfaser ist praktisch das Nonplusultra der Datenkabel und das ist kein Marketing-Gebrabbel oder ein Verkaufstrick, sondern technische Realität.
Bravo Mike, damit hast du aber Probleme, oder? Oder was hast du da? Du hast einen Satelliten-Receiver mit LAN.
Also da hast du doch Probleme, wenn du zum Beispiel private Sender in HD gucken willst. Das geht ja nur mit Smartcard.
Und dann hast du das Problem, das abzugreifen, das Signal wieder. Ja, ja, Free-TV, genau, genau.
Es ist übrigens absolut lächerlich, das muss ich jetzt aber an der Stelle mal sagen, wirklich komplett lächerlich, dass private Fernsehsender heute nur in SD senden.
Wenn du HD gucken willst, brauchst du, musst du Geld bezahlen und zusätzlich zu, du musst Geld bezahlen, können die noch verbieten, aufzunehmen oder Werbung zu überspringen in Aufnahmen. Also wer das macht, ist komplett braindead und lost.
ich guck den ganzen scheiß einfach nicht und wenn ich mal wirklich was gucke in pro 7 oder oder oder
oder sat 1 oder so dann gucke ich das über die join app ja das ist dann auch werbung ab und zu
aber das ist noch im rahmen also das wirklich komplett lächerlich wer dafür geld gibt es
Geld ausgibt es nicht mehr zu retten.
Besseres, um Daten zu übertragen.
Deshalb ist die Glasfaser schon seit Mitte der 80er Jahre das Standardmedium für das Rückgrat unserer Telekommunikationsnetze.
Nur Privatkunden, zumindest in Deutschland, waren bislang außen vor.
Zur Einordnung. Die Glasfaser dämpft das Licht pro Kilometer.
Grob 100 bis 1000 mal weniger als Telefon- oder Coaxial-Kabel in ihren jeweiligen Breitbandfrequenzbereichen.
Das erlaubt die Infrastruktur wieder so aufzubauen, wie einst unsere Telefoninfrastruktur vor dem Internetboom aussah.
Bündel Glasfaserkabel mit vielen Fasern werden aus den Verteilerzentren in günstige, passive Verteiler auf der Straße gelegt und von dort aus an die Kunden weiterverteilt.
Durch den extrem geringen Signalverlust beträgt die Reichweite auch ohne Verstärker Dutzende Kilometer, sogar mehr als früher bei der analogen Telefonie.
Das aktuell viel für Internetzugänge genutzte GPON-Protokoll kommt zum Beispiel grob 30 Kilometer weit, sodass man aus einem Verteilerzentrum gleich mehrere Stadtteile oder Dörfer versorgen kann.
Klar, der Glasfaserausbau kostet erstmal Milliarden von Euro.
Aber wir vermuten, dass die neue Struktur langfristig die Preise drücken wird, weil die Anbieter dadurch immens Kosten sparen.
Sie brauchen ja nicht mehr an x Straßenecken aktive Technik, sondern nur noch in den Verteilerzentren.
Und selbst da sparen sie Geld, weil die Splitting-Techniken mehrere Kunden pro Port erlauben.
Ein weiteres großes Argument ist die Störsicherheit.
Das Licht in der Faser kann nämlich nicht wie VDSL oder DOCSIS
durch elektromagnetische Strahlung in der Umgebung beeinflusst werden.
Es ist also egal, ob euer Nachbar ein rotziges Netzteil
oder ein Powerline Adapter ansteckt.
Interessiert das Licht in der Faser nicht und ihr bleibt online.
Klar wird ein defektes Glasfasermodem angesteckt, das dauerhaft sendet,
wird das zum Problem für die gesamte optische Domäne.
Aber das passiert laut unserem Stand extrem selten.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt noch fragt, ob bei diesen Leitungslängen
in zehn Jahren nicht wieder Bandbreitenflaschenhälse entstehen,
dann denkt ihr zwar gut mit, müsst euch aber keine Sorgen machen, denn die Bandbreite in der Glasfaser ist gigantisch.
Wirklich nicht übertrieben, sie ist gigantisch. Und das auch bei größeren Kabellängen.
Zur groben Einordnung. Das O-Band, also einer von fünf Frequenzbereichen in der Glasfaser, reicht von 1260 bis 1360 Nanometer.
Damit ist die Wellenlänge des Lichts gemeint, das die Faser transportieren kann.
Diese 100 Nanometer, 1260 bis 1360 Nanometer, die klingen erstmal sehr wenig, entsprechen aber einem gigantischen Block von 17 Terahertz.
Also 17 Millionen Megahertz.
Also 19.700 mal das, was das Coax-Kabelnetz gerade übertragen kann.
Und grob 500.000 mal der VDSL-Bandbreite.
Und es gibt ja noch vier weitere Frequenzblöcke.
Insgesamt sind so 50 Millionen Megahertz nutzbar.
Und das gilt für jeden modernen Glasfaseranschluss, denn der Glasfaserausbau wird nicht etwa mit billiger Kundenfaser gemacht, sondern mit dem Typ, der auch in Rechenzentren zum Einsatz kommt, um mehrere Terabit pro Sekunde zu übertragen.
Das können wir mit der richtigen Technik in jede Wohnung tun. Das macht man natürlich nicht, weil niemand das braucht, aber die Glasfaser ist somit nicht der begrenzende Faktor, sondern welche Technik man daran anschließt und welche Bandbreite diese ausnutzt.
Was uns zum letzten Argument bringt, Upload-Datenrate. Die Ablenkfrequenzblöcke bei DSL und DOX, das sind ja relativ klein, sodass man zum Beispiel im Kabelnetz so komische Tarife mit 1 GB pro Sekunde im Downstream und 40 MB pro Sekunde im Upstream buchen kann.
Das liegt einfach nur daran, dass da im Upstream nur 60 MHz Platz ist.
In der Glasfaser haben wir so viel Bandbreite frei, dass wir einfach die gleiche Geschwindigkeit in beide Richtungen fahren können.
Hier entsteht also eine Infrastruktur, die man aufgrund ihrer gigantischen Bandbreite und ihrer Störsicherheit zu Lebzeiten vermutlich nicht mehr ausbegraben muss, sofern sie keinen Bagger durchhackt.
Ergibt sich, dass wir zeitnah mehr Bandbreite brauchen, schließt man einfach beidseitig neue Technik an und ist schneller unterwegs.
Kein Baggern, kein Bohren, kein Kabel ziehen, denn es ist ja alles schon da, was man braucht.
Ihr Ersparnis über die Jahrzehnte ist also immens.
Übrigens, der Grund, weshalb ihr aktuell bei den meisten Anbietern nur bis zu 1 Gigabit pro Sekunde buchen könnt,
ist schlicht, dass diese derzeit hauptsächlich GPON verwenden.
Dabei werden 2,5 Gigabit pro Sekunde im Downstream und 1,25 Gigabit pro Sekunde im Upstream
über passive Splitter auf mehrere Kunden aufgeteilt.
Spart Energie und Kosten, weil pro Port mehrere Kunden versorgt werden.
Aber...
So Leute, das Video kommt immer noch fertig.
Mein Essen ist da.
Und dann wird Pippo Fett time.
abkriegen. XGS-PON mit 10
Gigabit pro Sekunde in beide Richtungen und
50G-PON mit 50 Gigabit pro Sekunde
in beide Richtungen für Tarife mit
2,5, 5, 10 oder sogar
mehr Gigabit pro Sekunde sind aber auch
schon verfügbar. Sobald die Anbieter ihre
Kernnetze aufgerückt haben. Ich hätte so gerne,
dass der Brief kommt so nach dem Motto, wir planen
einen Glasfaserausbau. Wollen Sie jetzt mitmachen?
Da sage ich, jawohl, will ich.
Ich bezahle
denen sogar das Aufreißen von der Straße
vom Haus.
Hauptsache ich kriege eine Glasfaserleit.
der erzählt einfach Schwachsinn. Wenn morgen mehr notwendig ist, können wir mit der Glasfaser
einfach mehr machen. Darum geht es halt. Genau deshalb ist dieser Ausbau die richtige Entscheidung
und auch so wichtig, dass wir alle daran mitwirken. Nur mit Glasfaser entsteht eine
Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur, mit der ihr heutige und zukünftige Anwendungen flüssig
nutzen könnt. Zusammengefasst, ihr wollt den Glasfaserausbau nicht verpassen, denn es lohnt
sich alleine wegen der Störsicherheit und der Zukunftstauglichkeit auf die Glasfaser umzusteigen,
Selbst wenn ihr zum Ausbauen nun einen Tarif mit vergleichsweise langsam 150 oder 300 Megabit pro Sekunde bucht, weil ihr nicht mehr braucht.
Das geht bei allen Anbietern und ihr könnt auch von heute auf morgen im Rahmen der technischen Möglichkeiten die Geschwindigkeit hochbuchen.
Lasst euch an der Haustür nichts anderes erzählen.
Nichts bescheißen, ja.
Okay, okay, okay, aber was nützt mir das denn alles, wenn kein Glasfaser aus bei mir geplant ist, aber demnächst DSL abgeschaltet wird und ich dann auf dem Trockenen sitze?
Schließlich liest man ja ständig in den Nachrichten davon, dass das passieren soll.
Tranquilo, Hombre.
Die Abschaltung von DSL und DOCSIS ist definitiv ein Ziel, auch politisch.
Aber bitte keine Panik.
Sie erfolgt nicht von heute auf morgen, nicht ohne vorangegangenen Glasfaserausbau bei euch
und nicht ohne Vorankündigung Jahre oder Monate vorher.
Außerdem wird euer Anbieter garantiert mehrfach versuchen, euch deshalb zu kontaktieren,
wenn ihr an einem betroffenen Anschluss hängt.
Ein Risiko gibt es jedoch.
Es gibt für Eigentümer ohne Mieter keine Pflicht, Glasfaser installieren zu lassen
und wenn ihr den Glasfaseranschluss wiederholt ablehnt, könnte es sein,
dass ihr irgendwann in einer Grundversorgung über 5G, LTE oder Satellit landet.
Die wird dann wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht sein, wahrscheinlich werdet ihr einige 100 Megabit pro Sekunde bekommen,
aber die Datenrate schwankt typischerweise stark und bei diesen Techniken sind Geschwindigkeitssprünge
wieder wesentlich kostenintensiver und langwieriger als bei der Glasfaser.
Außerdem gibt es schlicht physikalische Grenzen in diesem Universum,
die die Datenrate über diese Funktechniken im Vergleich zur Glasfaser stark limitieren.
Bringt der technische Fortschritt dann Anwendungen hervor, die mehr Datenrate benötigen,
zum Beispiel symmetrische...
Dass sie das nicht abschalten, bevor Glasfaser gelegt ist, will ich auch mal hoffen.
Ansonsten wäre es ja auch irgendwie komplett dämlich.
Wird schon so sein.
Und wie gesagt, sobald der Brief kommt, bin ich da am Start.
Ey, ich mache die Straße sogar selbst auf, wenn es sein muss.
Displays oder Taschen-MRTs, dann steht ihr wieder in der Warteschlange.
Wie damals ADSL oder V92-Kunden als HD-Videos und downloadbare Inhalte für Spiele im Internet auftauchten.
Ihr könnt da natürlich immer noch Glasfaser von der Straße aus legen lassen,
doch das wird wahrscheinlich einige tausend Euro kosten,
wenn für euch erneuter Tiefbauer samt Equipment anrufen muss.
Der gebündelte Ausbau ist ja meist sehr günstig oder sogar kostenlos, wenn man einen Tarif bucht.
Aber wie gesagt, das Risiko, dass ihr den Glasfaserausbau in eurer Straße verpasst, ist wirklich extrem gering. Lasst euch bitte keine Panik machen. Wenn euch jemand an der Haustür unter Vorgabe falscher Tatsachen versucht, zu einem Vertragsabschluss zu drängen, macht ihm die Tür vor der Nase zu und ruft selbst.
Ich mach die Tür erst gar nicht auf.
Wenn da wirklich was geplant ist, dann sehe ich das im Internet und ich bekomme Post.
Beim Ausbau einen Anbieter an. Welcher das ist, erfahrt ihr am meisten in den ersten zwei Sätzen von dem Verkäufer.
Beim Anbieter könnt ihr euch in Ruhe informieren, euch Infos zuschicken lassen, ein Tarif aussuchen, der zu euch passt und den Ausbau beauftragen.
Der penetrante Vertriebler an eurer Tür ist nicht derjenige, der entscheidet, ob ihr Glasfaser bekommt oder wann eure DSL-Verbindung abgeschaltet wird.
Wir hoffen, dieses Video hat eure offenen Fragen beantwortet und euch etwas geholfen, den technischen Hintergrund des Glasfaserausbaus zu verstehen.
Kleiner Tipp aber noch, wenn ihr Lust auf tiefgehende Artikel zu Glasfaser und anderen technischen Themen habt, ist vielleicht Heise Plus etwas für euch.
Vieles davon ist irgendwie zwar schon klar gewesen, aber nochmal gut zusammengefasst.
Chat.
Ich muss jetzt off. Ich muss unbedingt was futtern.
Ich hab mega Hunger.
Wir hören uns
im nächsten Video. Schön, dass ihr
dabei gewesen seid.
Wenn ihr noch gucken wollt nach künstlichem Storage
und
Nassgeräten von Ugreen, Festplatten
von Seagate, könnt ihr nochmal bei mir
im Profil vorbeigucken.
Kanalprofil oder Ausrufezeichen
Seagate, Ausrufezeichen Ugreen
im Chat.
Ausrufezeichen Alternate geht auch
wenn ihr euch das angucken
und über meinen Link
sich die günstigen Preise
sichern
wir hören uns im nächsten Stream
machts gut bis dann, see you